GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. THE
SENATE. LABOR. PUBLIC.
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER. WE
DO HAVE 15 ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY, WE ARE HOPING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MOMENTARILY
AND IF SO, WE ARE. WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. IT LOOKS
LIKE I'M GOING TO ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO CALL THE ROLL. OF
COURSE. CORTEZ HERE. CORTEZ
HERE. WILK PRESENT. WILK.
PRESENT. DURAZZO. GONZALEZ
LAIRD. LAIRD. HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. ALL RIGHT, LET'S ADDRESS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE ARE
FIVE ITEMS UP FOR CONSENT TODAY.
THOSE WOULD BE FIVE ITEMS. FOUR,
NINE, 11, 12 AND 15. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THOSE ITEMS? THE
CONSENT AGENDA. SENATOR LAIRD
MOVES THE CONSENT CALENDAR, AS
THE ASSISTANT TO TAKE A ROLL
CALL. VOTE, PLEASE. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CORTEZ. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE WILK. AYE. WILK.
AYE. DURAZZO GONZALEZ. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THREE
ZERO. AND LEAVE IT ON. CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WHO WERE PRESENT
TEMPORARILY. WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND START WITH AND GO IN
FILE ORDER, AND HOPEFULLY ALL
THE WAY THROUGH. WE'LL SEE HOW
THAT GOES. BUT THE FIRST
PRESENTER IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HANEY, AB, 1976. IN FACT, SOME
MEMBER HAS TWO BILLS, ITEM ONE
AND TWO. SO WE'LL ASK HIM TO
START WITH NUMBER ONE AND BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. AND THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS BILL. AB 1976 ENSURES
WIDESPREAD ACCESS TO NALOXONE IN
CALIFORNIA BY REQUIRING IT BE IN
ALL LOCATIONS THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE A WORKPLACE FIRST AID
KIT, DRUG OVERDOSES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE DEADLIER THAN CAR
ACCIDENTS AND HOMICIDES
COMBINED. IN 2022, OVER 7000
DEATHS WERE CAUSED BY AN OPIOID
OVERDOSE, WITH A GROWING NUMBER
OF THOSE DEATHS BEING YOUTH. AND
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH WHEN SOMEONE OVERDOSES IS
OFTEN HOW QUICKLY NALOXONE CAN
BE ACCESSED. FOR NALOXONE TO BE
EFFECTIVE AND SAVE A LIFE, IT
REQUIRES SOMEONE NEAR THE PERSON
OVERDOSING TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MEDICATION. BECAUSE OPIOID USERS
WHO ARE IN THE MIDST OF AN
OVERDOSE CANNOT SELF-ADMINISTER
THE MEDICATION. THE OPIOID
CRISIS IS HURTING AND KILLING
PEOPLE ALL OVER OUR STATE. IT IS
HAPPENING IN EVERY CITY AND
EVERY COMMUNITY. IT IS HAPPENING
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE ADDICTED TO
DRUGS, AND IT'S ALSO HAPPENING
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCIDENTALLY
INGESTING OR BEING POISONED,
JUST LIKE A FIRE EXTINGUISHER OR
A DEFIBRILLATOR. WE HOPE THAT WE
NEVER HAVE TO USE NALOXONE, BUT
THE RISK IS GREAT ENOUGH THAT IT
SHOULD BE THERE IN THE RARE
PLACE THAT WE DO. WE RECENTLY
SAW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
RELEASE A STATEMENT ENCOURAGING
LEADERS TO HAVE NALOXONE AND
FIRST AID KITS, RECOGNIZING THAT
EASY ACCESS TO NALOXONE IS KEY
TO SAVING LIVES. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, EVEN AS WE WORK IN ALL
DIFFERENT WAYS TO ATTACK THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC AND OVERDOSE
CRISIS. THERE HAS BEEN AGREEMENT
THAT ACCESS TO NALOXONE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL SHOULD GET
BEHIND, AND THIS IS THE MOST
ACCESSIBLE WAY TO DO IT. WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
MEREDITH HOLDER, AN EMERGENCY
ROOM NURSE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE EMERGENCY NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND TRENT MURPHY FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SO MANY WITNESSES TO
SPEAK FROM THE PODIUM, AND
YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES
EACH. PERFECT. THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY, MY NAME IS MEREDITH
HOLDER, AND I AM AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT NURSE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO, A CITY THAT HAS BEEN
RENOWNED FOR ITS BEAUTY AND
SPIRIT, BUT IS ALSO FACING THE
HARSH REALITY THE OPIOID CRISIS
HAS NOW HAS ONLY GOTTEN WORSE
NOW THAT FENTANYL IS EVERYWHERE,
SAN FRANCISCO IS NOT THE ONLY
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE FACING
THESE ISSUES, AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAYNIE SAID, THERE ARE
STAGGERING STATISTICS RIGHT NOW
SURROUNDING OPIOID DEATHS, IN
THAT IN 2022, OVER 7300 DEATHS
WERE CAUSED BY AN OPIOID
OVERDOSE, WITH AN INCREASING
NUMBER OF THOSE DEATHS BEING
YOUTH. I'M HERE TODAY SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF OVER 5000 NURSES OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 1976. THIS BILL IS
A PROACTIVE SOLUTION THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC
BY ENSURING WIDESPREAD ACCESS TO
NALOXONE, ALSO KNOWN AS NARCAN,
IN CALIFORNIA, BY REQUIRING IT
TO BE IN ALL LOCATIONS THAT HAVE
A FIRST AID KIT, NALOXONE IS A
MEDICATION THAT CAN REVERSE THE
EFFECTS OF AN OPIOID OVERDOSE
WITHIN MINUTES, AND IT IS A
CRITICAL MEDICATION. IN MY LINE
OF WORK, THIS IS A LIFE SAVING
DRUG. OVERDOSES CAN HAPPEN
ANYTIME, ANYWHERE. BY ENSURING
NALOXONE IS READILY AVAILABLE IN
WORKPLACE FIRST AID KITS, WE'RE
BEING PROACTIVE TO PREVENT
TRAGEDIES. PLACING NALOXONE, IN
FIRST AID KITS EQUIPS ORDINARY
CITIZENS WITH THE ABILITY TO
SAVE LIVES, MUCH LIKE USE OF A
FIRE EXTINGUISHER OR AN
AUTOMATIC EXTERNAL
DEFIBRILLATOR. OPIOID USERS IN
THE MIDST OF AN OVERDOSE CANNOT
SELF-ADMINISTER NALOXONE ONCE
THEY BECOME UNCONSCIOUS. THE
DRUG MUST BE READILY ACCESSIBLE
AND ADMINISTERED BY SOMEONE NEAR
THE PERSON. AS A NURSE, MY JOB
FIRST AND FOREMOST, IS TO ENSURE
PATIENT SAFETY AND TO ACT AS A
PATIENT ADVOCATE. TODAY, I
ADVOCATE FOR THOSE WHO I WILL
CARE FOR IN THE FUTURE, WHILE
THINKING OF THOSE WHO COULD HAVE
BEEN SAVED BY NALOXONE
ADMINISTERED BY A BYSTANDER IN
THE PAST. PLEASE SUPPORT
CREATING MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO NALOXONE TO PREVENT OPIOID
OVERDOSE DEATHS. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS TRENT MURPHY. I'M A
POLICY ANALYST REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES, ALSO KNOWN AS CADP.
WE'RE A PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION
WHICH REPRESENTS THE BACKBONE OF
THE STATE'S PUBLICLY FUNDED AND
COMMUNITY BASED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT NETWORK, AND
WE'RE A PROUD SUPPORTERS OF THIS
BILL. EVERY MOMENT MATTERS IN
THE EVENT OF AN OVERDOSE,
OVERDOSES CAN RESULT IN DEATH,
SEVERE BRAIN DAMAGE, AND OTHER
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS, ALL OF
WHICH CAN BE PREVENTED WITH THE
QUICK ADMINISTRATION OF AN
OPIOID ANTAGONIST. OPIOID
ANTAGONISTS RAPIDLY BLOCKED THE
EFFECTS OF OPIOIDS IN THE BRAIN,
WHICH CAN POTENTIALLY RESTORE
NORMAL, NORMAL BREATHING WITHIN
2 TO 3 MINUTES, AND THEY POSE NO
RISK TO THOSE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING A MEDICAL EMERGENCY
THAT IS UNRELATED TO AN OVERDOSE
, WHICH MAKES IT SAFE FOR A
BYSTANDER TO ADMINISTER THE
OPIOID ANTAGONIST TO AN
UNCONSCIOUS PERSON. EVEN IF THEY
HAVE LITTLE TO NO TRAINING. THE
MOST RECENT STATISTICS WE HAVE
ON WORKPLACE OVERDOSES ARE FROM
2022, AND IN THAT YEAR,
OVERDOSES ACCOUNTED FOR MORE
THAN 100 WORKPLACE DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING ABOUT
22% OF THE WORKPLACE FATALITIES
IN THE STATE. NOW, THIS IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT STATISTIC
WORTHY OF BEING ADDRESSED ALL ON
ITS OWN. BUT THIS ALSO FAILS TO
ENCAPSULATE THAT, THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO SAVE LIVES OF ANYONE
IN OR NEAR A WORKPLACE,
INCLUDING CUSTOMERS AND
BYSTANDERS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
AN OVERDOSE AS WELL. BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT THIS IS A CRUCIAL
MEASURE THAT WILL SAVE LIVES,
AND IT BUILDS UPON THE RECENT
WORK CALIFORNIA HAS DONE TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO OPIOID
ANTAGONISTS AND COMBAT THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHERS IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO STEP FORWARD AND
EXPRESS A SUPPORT POSITION,
NAME, AFFILIATION, AND SUPPORT?
PLEASE CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
OF BETTE FRANCO. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, AND SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
BRIAN MIRAMONTES, BASS, ME,
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE AN OPPOSITION
WITNESS, SEEING NONE. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO STEP FORWARD AND
EXPRESS AN OPPOSITION POSITION?
IF SO, DO SO NOW, SEEING NONE,
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR LAIRD, I'M
SORRY. WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSITION
COMMENT AT. RICHARD MARKUSON FOR
THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION. WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS, IN TREATMENT
OF DRUG OVERDOSE. HOWEVER, FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY, THERE
ARE ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
SAFE STORAGE AND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF NALOXONE, AND WE
HOPE THAT THAT WILL BE
ADDRESSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL WE'LL COUNT THAT AS A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. THANK YOU.
BACK TO SENATOR LAIRD. ACTUALLY,
THAT WAS THE QUESTION I WAS
GOING TO ASK, BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD BILL, AND WE'LL
VOTE TO MOVE IT ALONG. BUT HOW
DO YOU INTEND TO ADDRESS THE
STORAGE ISSUE, SINCE THIS WOULD
BE STORED AT SUCH DECENTRALIZED
PLACES THAT AREN'T TEMPERATURE
CONTROLLED AND ACCORDING TO THE
CRITICISM, IT NEEDS TO BE STORED
BETWEEN 68 AND 77 FAIR
FAHRENHEIT TO MAINTAIN PROPER
EFFICACY. Kò HOW WOULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE IN THIS BILL?
SO, YOU KNOW, WE'VE REVIEWED THE
RESEARCH ON THIS. FIRST OF ALL,
YOU KNOW, THESE THESE NEED TO BE
EVERYWHERE, CLEARLY, BECAUSE
THERE'S THE RISK IS EVERYWHERE.
IN FACT, ON CONSTRUCTION SITES,
A CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
EXPERIENCE A HIGHER RATE OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS. THERE WAS AN
ESTIMATE THAT 15% OF ALL OR CDC
SAID THAT CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
EXPERIENCED 15% OF ALL WORKPLACE
OVERDOSE DEATHS, DESPITE
REPRESENTING. I'M NOT ARGUING
THAT IT THAT IT DOESN'T NEED TO
BE EVERYWHERE. I'M JUST SAYING
WHEN IT IS EVERYWHERE, HOW DO
YOU MAKE SURE FOR THOSE PEOPLE
IT'S SAFE AND MAINTAINING ITS
EFFICACY? SURE. SO SO
CONSTRUCTION FIRST AID KITS ARE
CURRENTLY HIGHLY REGULATED BY
CAL OSHA. AND SO AS PART OF
THIS, WE INSTRUCT AT CAL OSHA TO
CREATE THE STANDARDS RELATED TO
NALOXONE AND FIRST AID KIT. SO
THEY WOULD BE DEVELOPING HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WITHIN
CONSTRUCTION SITES. THE RESEARCH
THAT WE'VE SEEN HERE DOES SAY
THAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE KEPT
BETWEEN 68 AND 77 DEGREES, BUT
SHORT EXPOSURES TO MORE EXTREME
TEMPERATURES, WHETHER MUCH LOWER
OR MUCH HIGHER, SHOULD NOT
AFFECT THE EFFICACY OR SHELF
LIFE OF NARCAN, THERE'S ALSO
RESEARCH THAT, THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO WITHSTAND MORE EXTREME
TEMPERATURES, AND, AND ALLOWING
THE APPROPRIATE USE. SO THERE
IS, DEFINITELY AN APPROPRIATE
LEVEL IN TERMS OF THE
TEMPERATURE. IT CAN WITHSTAND
MORE EXTREME TEMPERATURES FOR,
FOR ITS USE. BUT I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT INSTRUCTING THE,
THE CAL OSHA AS AN AUTHORITY TO
DETERMINE HOW BEST TO KEEP THESE
IN CONSTRUCTION SITES, I THINK
IS THE BEST STEP FOR US. SO DOES
THE BILL INSTRUCT CAL OSHA TO DO
THAT? AND DOES IT SAY THAT IT
CAN'T BE STORED UNLESS THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE A REGULATION THAT
GUARANTEES ITS SAFETY AND
EFFICACY? SENATOR, THERE'S
SENATOR, IF I COULD JUST JUMP.
SURE. THERE'S A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT THAT ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE. AND IN FACT, I SHOULD
HAVE ASKED THE AUTHOR IF HE'S
GOING TO TAKE THAT AMENDMENT.
WHY DON'T YOU ASK HIM IF HE'S
GOING TO TAKE IT AND HAVE
SOMEBODY EXPLAIN WHAT IT IS?
SURE I STARTED OUT SAYING I
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT, SO. ABSOLUTELY, THE
AMENDMENT, I THINK, DOES CLARIFY
THAT, THAT THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AS PART OF
THE CREATION OF THE STANDARDS.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING. IT SAYS
IT PROVIDES GUIDANCE, AND I'M
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
THAT IN FACT, IT'S GOING TO GET
ADDRESSED AND HOW THIS IS
HAPPENING. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
BASED ON THE ANALYSIS AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE RECOMMENDED
BY THE COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. THAT WAS THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'RE ACCEPTING. I DON'T
HAVE THE AMENDMENTS DIRECTLY IN
FRONT OF ME, BUT I. OKAY. WELL,
THEN LET ME JUST ASK THIS. I'M
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO VOTE TO MOVE
THIS ALONG. AND IT'S GOING TO
KEEP MOVING. BUT I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO ASSESS WHETHER IT
ACTUALLY ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT. AS SOMEBODY THAT
SPENDS HIS ENTIRE LIFETIME
HOLDING PRESCRIPTION BOTTLES UP
TO FIND OUT THE DATE AND, AND
TRY TO FIGURE IT OUT, THAT'S
WHEN YOU KNOW THIS, THIS IS A
LIFE AND DEATH THING. WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO HAVE IT OUT THERE AND
NOT BE, YOU KNOW, NOT BE ABLE TO
WORK. SO I WOULD JUST ASK THAT
YOU DETERMINE THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE
ISSUE AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
AND MR. CHAIR, I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR AND
THANK YOU. I DIDN'T HEAR YOU SAY
THAT YOU WERE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS EARLY ON. APPRECIATE
YOU CLARIFYING THAT. AND PERHAPS
JUST SOME CLARIFICATION. I KNOW
IT'S A IT'S A RULEMAKING
REQUEST, AND THE BILL REQUIRES
FORMAL RULEMAKING, BUT MAYBE
JUST SOME CLARIFICATION, EITHER
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE STAFF OR
THE AUTHOR HIMSELF. ULTIMATELY,
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE OSHA
INTENDS TO INCLUDE FOOD, THAT
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO CALL IT,
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE, BASICALLY, IN
TERMS OF HOW TO STORE IN THE
RULEMAKING ITSELF, BECAUSE I
THINK THEN THEN THERE'S PROBABLY
ABOUT AS BINDING AS IT CAN GET,
BUT THAT WOULD BE MY SUGGESTION
FOR ALL CONCERNED, THAT SAID,
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
. I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS, THIS
ISSUE, OBVIOUSLY, WE WANT THE
NALOXONE TO BE THERE. WE ALSO
WANT IT TO BE TO ACTUALLY WORK.
AND SO MAKING SURE THAT THE AS
AS PRESCRIPTIVE OR INTENTIONAL
AS THE GUIDANCE THAT OSHA
PROVIDES AROUND THESE STANDARDS
AND HOW THEY SHOULD, HOW IT
SHOULD BE STORED AS POSSIBLE, WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT
LANGUAGE. SO I'LL REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS. AND IF THERE ARE
WAYS TO STRENGTHEN IT WITHIN
WHAT WE CAN DO FOR OSHA'S
RULEMAKING PROCESS, WE WILL DO
THAT. AND YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT. AND WITH THAT, THANK
YOU. AND RESPECTFULLY, AT THE
RIGHT TIME, I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT TIME,
SENATOR. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T.
THERE MIGHT NOT BE ENOUGH VOTES
HERE, BUT THERE WILL BE RIGHT?
RIGHT. SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND WE CAN WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
EARLIER SO WE CAN TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE OF THOSE PRESENT. AND
I'LL ASK THE ASSISTANT TO DO
THAT. PLEASE ON FILE ITEM ONE,
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR CORTEZ.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. WILK. DURAZO.
GONZALEZ LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. TWO ZERO. KEEP THE BILL
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS,
THAT'S A GOOD START, I THINK.
AND WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM TWO,
WHICH IS AB 2182. AND YOU'RE
WELCOME TO PRESENT ON THAT BILL.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. AB 2182 IS CRUCIAL
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ENSURE
EQUITABLE PAY FOR CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA BY
ADDRESSING SEVERAL SHORTCOMINGS
OF CURRENT PREVAILING WAGE LAW
AND ENFORCEMENT. FIRST, AB 20
2182 ENSURES THAT WORKERS
RECEIVE THE CURRENT PREVAILING
WAGES ON PROJECTS REGARDLESS OF
WHEN A PROJECT WAS ANNOUNCED FOR
BID. RIGHT NOW, WORKERS ARE
FORCED TO TAKE THE PREVAILING
WAGE FOR WHEN THE PROJECT WAS
FIRST ANNOUNCED, EVEN IF IT IS
YEARS BEFORE THE PROJECT
ACTUALLY BREAKS GROUND, OR IF
THERE IS A LOWER WAGE IN PLACE.
THIS ADJUSTMENT IS ESSENTIAL TO
MAINTAIN EQUITY WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY AND ENSURE WORKERS ARE
RECEIVING ADEQUATE WAGES.
SECOND, THE BILL WILL STRENGTHEN
THE ABILITY OF THE STATE TO
ENFORCE PREVAILING WAGE LAW,
INCLUDING GRANTING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES
REASONABLE ACCESS TO ACTIVE
PUBLIC WORK JOB SITES AND
PROVIDE STATUTORY ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO REQUEST
CERTIFIED PAYROLL INFORMATION SO
THE STATE CAN HOLD CONTRACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR PAYING FAIR
WAGES. LASTLY, THIS BILL WILL
UPDATE ANNUAL IZATION PAYMENTS
TO ALIGN CALIFORNIA LAW WITH
FEDERAL REGULATIONS SO THAT
WORKERS ARE PROPERLY COMPENSATED
FOR THEIR WORK, I WANT TO ALSO
LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
AMENDMENTS WE CAN TAKE ON THE
FLOOR TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
WE DO HAVE AN INACTIVE
CONVERSATION. IT'S HAPPENING
AROUND SOME SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED, AND I AM
HOPEFUL THAT WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON THAT, WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY TODAY IS KEITH DUNN,
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES. AND HE IS ALSO ABLE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. SENATORS, KEITH DUNN
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES, AS
MR. HANEY HAS INDICATED, WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION. I
WILL TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE GOT
AMENDMENTS PREPARED TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS WITH REGARDS TO
LIABILITY OF PROVIDING ACCESS TO
THE LLCS, TO THE JOB SITES. I
THINK THAT YOU'LL HEAR FROM, THE
FOLKS THAT WERE MOSTLY THERE. WE
HAVEN'T GOT 100% AGREEMENT, BUT
I THINK WE'VE ADDRESSED A NUMBER
OF THEIR CONCERNS. I WOULD SAY
THE MAJORITY OF THEIR CONCERNS,
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS,
PROTECTION FOR THE LRMC
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE ON THE JOB
SITE AND THAT LIABILITY ISN'T
SHIFTED TO THE OWNER OR THE
CONTRACTOR. PRINCIPALLY, I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT WITH
REGARDS TO, SOME OF THE
PREVAILING WAGE ISSUES FOR SOME
CONTRACTORS, I THINK IT'S HIGH
TIME THAT WE STOPPED PROVIDING
LOW INTEREST, NO INTEREST LOANS
TO PUBLIC WORKS ON THE BACKS OF
NON-REPRESENTED WORKERS. I THINK
THIS BILL GOES A LONG WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
PAID THE WAGES, BENEFITS THAT
THEY'RE OWED WHEN THEY'RE
GETTING. IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
NONE OF US WOULD WANT TO GET A,
A, A WAGE INCREASE, THEN TOLD
YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT IN SIX
MONTHS. BUT YOU GOT TO KEEP
WORKING HERE. I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS OVER INCREASED COSTS OF
CONSTRUCTION. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT FACES ALL OF US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WORK IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FIELD. BUT WE
HAVE COST INCREASES ON MATERIALS
AND OTHER THINGS THAT IMPACT
JOBS, AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT FOR
WITH REGARDS TO CONCERNS OVER,
ALTERNATIVE DELIVERY. I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THOSE PROJECTS FOR
OVER A DECADE, AND ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT'S AUTHORIZED THAT, AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE DELIVERING A PROJECT WITH
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF MECHANISM,
TO PROCURE IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
REALITIES OF THE MARKET, WHICH
MEANS YOU WILL HAVE COST
INCREASES, ESPECIALLY ON
PROJECTS THAT TAKE YEARS TO
COMPLETE. SO THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT WE CAN WORK THROUGH, BUT WE
SHOULD NOT BE DOING IT ON THE
BACKS OF WORKERS. WITH THAT, I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, WE WILL NOW ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO STEP FORWARD
AND OFFER SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
MATT CREMEANS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS. WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
MARTIN VENDIOLA, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS, THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS, AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, GREG LEWIS, UA
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
761, IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS JOHN HERSHEY WITH UA
LOCAL 447 PLUMBERS AND PIPE
FITTERS HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, ANDRES POSADA, ON
BEHALF OF THE LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMPLIANCE COUNCIL IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL TURN TO OPPOSITION. IS
THERE AN OPPOSITION WITNESS?
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. YOU'LL
HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS MELANIE
PERRON, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
OF CALIFORNIA, WE'RE THE LARGEST
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING GENERAL
CONTRACTORS, BOTH LARGE AND
SMALL, FIRST, I WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR ABOUT THE
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE LIABILITY ISSUE ON THE WORK
SITES FOR LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEES. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORKING WITH THEM
TO SOLVE THAT CONCERN, HOWEVER,
WHAT I REALLY DO WANT TO FOCUS
ON IS THIS BILL AND THE
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT EXPANDING
REQUIREMENTS IN PUBLIC WORKS AND
OTHER BILLS THAT ARE ALSO
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF
PUBLIC WORKS. WE'RE REALLY
GETTING TO A POINT THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO HAVE CONTRACTORS
THAT ARE UNWILLING TO BID ON
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. SOME OF
OUR LARGER CONTRACTORS THAT MAY
NOT BE AN ISSUE, BUT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SMALLER
CONTRACTORS AND OPENING UP
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESSIBILITY TO
BENEFITING FROM PUBLIC DOLLARS
ON THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS,
THERE'S AN UNWILLINGNESS.
THEY'RE STARTING TO FEEL MORE
AND MORE THE PINCH OF THE
ABILITY FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
BID AND TO PERFORM WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS. AND AS WE LOOK AT
LIKE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE TEN
DAY TURNAROUND, WHICH I
APPRECIATE THAT IT IS IN
RULEMAKING, SMALLER CONTRACTORS
ARE HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
AM I GOING TO BE ON A WORK SITE
TODAY, OR AM I GOING TO HAVE TO
GO AND QUICKLY FULFILL A RECORDS
ACT REQUEST BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER? FURTHER, THE
CAMPAÑA ABOUT THE APPEALS
PROCESS, THE WRIT OF MANDATE
WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER. SO,
AGAIN, OUR LARGER CONTRACTORS
MAY BE NOT AS SO MUCH AN ISSUE.
BUT YOU TALK ABOUT BONDING
REQUIREMENTS. A LOT OF OUR
SMALLER CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MEET THOSE
BONDING REQUIREMENTS TO FILE A
WRIT OF MANDATE. WE WANT TO MAKE
THIS AN EVEN PLAYING FIELD. WE
WANT TO GO AND OPEN THE DOOR FOR
THESE SMALLER CONTRACTORS. AND
WE'RE STRUGGLING ABOUT HOW THIS
IS NOW CLOSING THE DOOR
ACTUALLY. SO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE, WITH THIS OFFER AND
THE LEGISLATURE. AND HOW DO WE
FIND ADDITIONAL PATHS FORWARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SMALLER
CONTRACTORS CAN BENEFIT ON
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS? THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. STEVE CRUZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE IN OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION PRIMARILY AROUND
SECTION TWO AND THE JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE. WE DID
MEET RECENTLY WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND WITH THE SPONSORS.
AND AS INDICATED BY MR. DUNN,
OUR CONCERNS IS ON THE PROPERTY
OWNER SIDE ARE RELATIVE TO
LIABILITY AND ACCESS, AND WE
THINK WE WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS. SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR. BUT AS OF NOW
WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE OPEN
FOR MEETINGS NOW. GOOD MORNING,
ANTHONY TANNEHILL, CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION,
WE ARE A CONCERNS, THOSE WERE
YOUR YOU'RE ALLOWED NOW TO SAY
THAT YOU'RE OPPOSED IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED AND YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THAT'S IT. WE'RE
BEYOND THE LEAD WITNESSES. THANK
YOU CHAIR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. GOOD MORNING.
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. RICHARD MARCUSSEN
FOR WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS.
SCOTT. GOVERNOR, ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION, WE ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. SO WE ARE A TRAINER.
WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, CONCLUDES WITNESS
TESTIMONY AND MEETINGS. WE WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY DISCUSSION AND SEEING NONE,
WE'LL GIVE THE AUTHOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK IN PARTICULAR
ON THIS ISSUE AROUND THE
LIABILITY AND ACCESS TO THE JOB
SITES. AND I THINK WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF PROGRESS ON THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. SO HOPEFULLY
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK THOSE
ISSUES OUT. AND THIS IS IN A
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR
FAIRNESS AND EQUITY AND ENSURING
, THAT WE HAVE WORKERS THAT WE
NEED FOR THESE CRITICAL PUBLIC
JOBS. WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN, WE
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S TESTIMONY.
IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS ITEM?
SO MOVED. SENATOR LAIRD MOVES
THE MOTION AND I'LL ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO RESTATE IT AND CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM TWO. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR CORTESE Ã CORTESE I
WILK DURAZZO. GONZALEZ. LAIRD I
LAIRD I. ALL RIGHT. SO WE'RE AT
2 TO 0 AND LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. THREE MEMBERS
HERE. I SEE THAT. NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM THREE, AB 1997
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA. YOU MAY
COME FORWARD AND PRESENT WHEN
READY.
GOOD. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB 1997 SIMPLIFIES
CALSTRS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE TO REDUCE REPORTING
ERRORS, ADDRESS FINDINGS, UPDATE
BENEFIT CHANGES, AND CORRECT
OVERPAYMENTS THAT MAY HAVE
OCCURRED AT CALSTRS. THIS BILL
HAD HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY, AND IT
DOES NOT HAVE OPPOSITION, NO NO
VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND IT
DOES NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO BRING UP
WITNESSES. JOCELYN MARTINEZ HèA,
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT
SYSTEM, AND DEREK LENNOX, SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS AND LEGAL AFFAIRS AT
THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION, ARE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY. YOU'LL HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR ALL LEAD
WITNESSES. THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. I'M HAPPY TO
BE HERE. JOYCELYN MARTINEZ WADE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM. THE
SPONSORS OF AB 1997. THIS HAS
BEEN A CONSENSUS BASED APPROACH
WITH OUR MEMBER AND EMPLOYER
PARTNERS, AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
WITH THE WORK WE'VE DONE OVER
MORE THAN A YEAR TO SIMPLIFY, TO
FIND LANGUAGE THAT SIMPLIFIES
OUR CREDIBLE COMPENSATION AND
CREDIBLE SERVICE STATUTES. THIS
WILL AVOID REPORTING ERRORS,
AUDIT FINDINGS, BENEFIT
OVERPAYMENTS AND PENALTIES, AND
INTEREST FOR OUR EMPLOYERS. AND
SO WE ARE FOCUSING ON POSITION
SUBJECT TO MEMBERSHIP,
REDEFINING CREDIBLE COMPENSATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN OUR PEPRA AND
PREPARE FOLKS, SPECIFYING
ANNUALIZED PAY RATE, HAVING MORE
MEMBER CONTRIBUTIONS COUNT
TOWARD THE DEFINED BENEFIT
SUPPLEMENT BENEFIT AND ALLOWING
SUPPLEMENTAL PAY TO CREATE
SERVICE CREDIT WHILE NOT
ADJUSTING FINAL COMPENSATION. SO
THIS BILL ALSO HELPS AVOID
MANIPULATION THAT COULD HAPPEN
UNDER CURRENT LAW. SO FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS, WE THANK THE
AUTHOR VERY MUCH FOR PUTTING
THIS FORWARD. AND WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
DEREK LENNOX, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS REPRESENTING THE
58 COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOLS, WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AB
1997. AND I WANT TO START BY
CREDITING THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND CALSTRS FOR THE CONSENSUS
BASED APPROACH THAT WAS JUST
MENTIONED, THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS LAW, TECHNICAL AND NUANCED
AS THEY ARE, ARE THE RESULT OF
DEEP INQUIRY FROM EMPLOYER
ASSOCIATIONS, EMPLOYEE
ASSOCIATIONS, RETIREE
ASSOCIATIONS, ALL WORKING
TOGETHER WITH CALSTRS. FOR OUR
PART, THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
REPORT THE COMPENSATION AND
SERVICE CREDIT OF EMPLOYEES FOR
THE VAST MAJORITY OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO CALSTRS AS IT FUNNELS
THROUGH THE COUNTY OFFICES. SO
THE FOLKS THAT I WORK WITH HAVE
FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE OF THE WAYS
THAT THE PROCESS WORKS WELL, AND
ALSO WHERE THESE EMPLOYER
REPORTING ERRORS ARE OCCURRING,
OFTEN IN SPITE OF THE GOOD WORK
TO TRY AND CORRECT AND AVOID
THOSE ERRORS, TWO YEARS AGO, AB
1667 WAS ENACTED TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYERS COULD RECEIVE TIMELY,
ACCURATE AND CONSISTENT
REPORTING ADVICE FROM CALSTRS
AND IMPORTANTLY, TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO RETIRED MEMBERS
IMPACTED BY OVERPAYMENTS DUE TO
REPORTING ERRORS. SO WHILE THAT
BILL ADDRESSED THE IMPACTS OF
THE REPORTING ERRORS, THIS BILL
NOW ADDRESSES THEIR ROOT CAUSE
BY SIMPLIFYING SEVERAL IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS WITHIN THE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT LAW THAT COMMONLY
CONTRIBUTE TO REPORTING ERRORS.
SO WITH THAT SAID, I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND PLEASE
JUST SUPPORT THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WE CAN NOW ACCEPT,
FURTHER TESTIMONY FROM FOLKS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO, EXPRESS A SUPPORT
POSITION, NAME AND AFFILIATION
ONLY. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MARTHA ZARAGOZA. DÍAS AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE DELTA KAPPA
GAMMA, CALIFORNIA. AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL FOR ALL THE
REASONS THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN
BEFORE BY THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, STAFF, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. PAMELA GIBBS,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. ELIZABETH ESQUIVEL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS,
REPRESENTING OVER 30,000 SCHOOL
BUSINESS LEADERS STATEWIDE IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, DOROTHY
JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF ACSA, THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. LETICIA
GARCIA, ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IN SUPPORT. ANA MATHEWS, ON
BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT. WITNESSES
STEPPING FORWARD. DO WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS SEEING NO ONE
STEP FORWARD? IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS AN OPPOSITION POSITION
WITH THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. IF SO,
SEEING NONE, WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE NOT IN A
POSITION TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
RIGHT NOW, GIVEN THE CHAIR IS
THE ONLY ONE PRESENT SUBSTITUTE
CHAIR AT THAT. BUT, IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOUR
WELCOME TO DO THAT. AND THEN WE
WILL TAKE UP THE BILL AS SOON AS
WE HAVE MEMBERS, ABSENT MEMBERS
BACK. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE BEING HERE. WE ARE. I'M
NOT CLEAR IF WE HAVE ANOTHER,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERE. ANOTHER
AUTHOR. IT LOOKS LIKE. NOT, WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE AND
FOLLOW ORDER IF WE CAN GET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO HERE, WE
WILL PAUSE FOR A MOMENT, TAKE AN
INFORMAL RECESS WHILE WE ARE,
AWAITING AN AUTHOR, WHICH MEANS
IT'S OKAY TO MOVE AROUND A
LITTLE BIT WHILE YOU HAVE A
CHANCE, BUT WE ARE GOING TO CALL
IT RIGHT BACK TO ORDER AS SOON
AS WE HAVE AN AUTHOR. THANK YOU.
MAN GOOD MORNING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WE ARE ON YOUR ITEM.
IT'S PHÐ ITEM FIVE, AB 2135. AND
YOU'RE WELCOME. YOU'RE WELCOME
TO COME FORWARD, THROUGH THE
GATE TO THIS PODIUM TO TESTIFY.
AND WE'LL TAKE. I'M SORRY, NOT
TESTIFY, BUT TO PRESENT. WE'LL
TAKE YOUR PRESENTATION WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. COME UP HERE. THEY
ARE GOING TO TESTIFY FROM THE
PODIUM OUT HERE. THANK YOU FOR
ASKING. IT'S BEEN A YEAR. I
DON'T REMEMBER HOW IT WORKS OVER
HERE, GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. SPEAKER. AND
MEMBERS, WAGE THEFT AFFECTS TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF WORKERS EVERY
YEAR IN NEARLY EVERY FIELD. FOR
FAMILIES LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK, WAGE THEFT MAKES
BALANCING BUDGETS IMPOSSIBLE.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE SAME
INDIVIDUALS OFTEN DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO SEEK JUSTICE WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. BAD ACTORS
ALSO CREATE A DISADVANTAGE FOR
HONEST CONTRACTORS LIVING UP TO
THE HIGH STANDARDS WE HOLD IN
CALIFORNIA FOR PUBLIC WORKS, THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATION FOR PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECT LABOR VIOLATION
INVESTIGATIONS IS CREATING
SITUATIONS WHERE NOT ONLY ARE
WORKERS COMPLAINTS CLOSED
PREMATURELY, BUT BAD ACTORS CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AB 2135
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL TIME FOR THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER TO CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS AND ENSURE
JUSTICE IS SERVED. AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL TAKE EFFECT SHOULD AB
2135 PASS THIS COMMITTEE AIMS TO
RESPOND TO CONCERNS THAT IT
WOULD HAVE ALLOWED FOR
INVESTIGATIONS TO CONTINUE
WITHOUT A LIMIT. INSTEAD, THE
AMENDMENTS ALLOW THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO MAKE A ONE TIME
EXTENSION FOR A SHOWING OF GOOD
CAUSE. WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CONTRACTOR ECOSYSTEM
BENEFITS BOTH FROM GOOD ACTORS
AND WORKERS, AND PROVIDING THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER MORE TIME TO
INVESTIGATE CASES WILL HELP TO
DO THAT. I'M JOINED TODAY BY
GREG LEWIS, BUSINESS MANAGER FOR
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
761, AND ANDRES POSADA, DIRECTOR
OF LABOR MANAGEMENT COMPLIANCE
COUNSEL, AS WITNESSES. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
GENTLEMEN. YOU MAY TESTIFY HERE
FROM THE PODIUM. YOU HAVE A
COUPLE MINUTES EACH. OKAY, GOOD
MORNING, COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS GREG LEWIS. I'M THE
BUSINESS MANAGER OF THE PLUMBERS
AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL 761,
REPRESENTING OVER A THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN LA COUNTY. I CAME
HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU TO STAND
WITH WORKING FAMILIES AND VOTE
YES ON AB 2135. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT WHETHER CALIFORNIANS
WORKING ON PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
ARE PAID APPROPRIATELY, UNDER
THE CURRENT PREVAILING WAGE
LAWS, ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS HAS
IMPACTED WORKERS IS A PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECT IN MY HOMETOWN OF
SANTA CLARITA. IT WAS A SENIOR
CENTER, PREVAILING WAGE
VIOLATIONS WERE FOUND ON SEVERAL
CONTRACTORS ON THAT JOB,
INCLUDING NOT SUBMITTING THE
REQUIRED FORMS, NOT HIRING
APPRENTICES, INCORRECT
JOURNEYMEN TO APPRENTICE RATIO.
MISCLASSIFYING. WORKERS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, FAILURE TO PAY
PREVAILING WAGES. CASE AGAINST
THESE CONTRACTORS WERE OPENED
WITH THE DLSS IN 2020, AND WERE
UNDER INVESTIGATION UNTIL THEY
REACH THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
IN 2023 AND WERE JUST SIMPLY
CLOSED, SO THE PEOPLE ON THE JOB
GETTING DIRTY, DIGGING DITCHES,
INSTALLING PIPE, FIRE
SPRINKLERS, AIR CONDITIONING,
TOILETS AND EVERYTHING ELSE WERE
NOT APPROPRIATELY PAID FOR THEIR
WORK ON THAT JOB, AND THE
CONTRACTORS SIMPLY GOT AWAY WITH
IT. AND UNFORTUNATELY, THIS
HAPPENS ALL TOO OFTEN, AFFECTING
UNION AND NONUNION WORKERS
ALIKE, WITH TODAY'S COST OF
LIVING, THE LAST THING WE CAN
ACCEPT IS WORKERS BEING RIPPED
OFF. THIS IS NOT A VICTIMLESS
CRIME. THESE ARE CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLING TO KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEADS. AND WHEN WORKERS
GET RIPPED OFF, PEOPLE LOSE
THEIR HOMES, FAMILIES BREAK UP,
AND WE ALL PAY A PRICE FOR THAT.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT WORKERS
GET PAID THE MONEY THEY'VE
EARNED, THAT AWARDING AGENCIES
AND TAXPAYERS GET WHAT THEY PAID
FOR, AND IT WILL HOLD BAD
CONTRACTORS ACCOUNTABLE. THAT'S
WHY I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON AB. ONE 2135 THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS ANDRES POSADA AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMPLIANCE
COUNCIL. WE'RE A JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COOPERATION COMMITTEE
THAT MONITORS COMPLIANCE WITH
THE PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE APPLICABLE TO PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS. I HAVE BEEN
WORKING IN THIS FIELD FOR OVER
15 YEARS, AND DURING THE LAST
SIX, WE HAVE BEEN PARTNERING
ACTIVELY WITH THE DIVISION OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT, OR
DLC. WE'RE CONTINUOUSLY
CO-HOSTING EDUCATIONAL AND
OUTREACH EVENTS, AND WE ARE
SENDING TO THEM COMPLAINTS ABOUT
LABOR COMPLIANCE VIOLATIONS.
HOWEVER, FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS, MY AGENCY AS WELL AS MANY
OTHERS WITHIN THE STATE, HAVE
SEEN ON AVERAGE, THAT 25% OF OUR
COMPLAINTS THAT HAVE BEEN SENT
TO THE STATE WITH AMPLE TIME
HAVE REACHED THEIR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS, AND IT IS IMPORTANT
HERE TO SAY THAT THESE
COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN SENT, YOU
KNOW, IN SOME CASES WITH MORE
THAN TWO YEARS BEFORE THAT,
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS KICKS IN.
NOW, SINCE THE DLC IS THE LAST
LINE OF DEFENSE WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECT THE WORKERS RIGHTS ON
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS, THE
CLOSURE OF THESE CASES OBVIOUSLY
HAS DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON
WORKERS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
EXPLOITATION OR UNFAIR
TREATMENT. THIS ALSO PERPETUATES
THE CYCLE OF INJUSTICE, ALLOWING
UNSCRUPULOUS EMPLOYERS TO ESCAPE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS, AND FURTHERMORE, THE
CLOSURE OF THESE CASES BECAUSE
OF THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
HAS BEEN REACHED MAY UNDERMINE
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
ENFORCEMENT OF LABOR LAWS. NOW,
BY BY NOW, WE ARE ALL AWARE THAT
THE EXTENT OF CASE BACKLOG THAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER OFFICE
AND BY EXTENSION, THE DLC IS
EXPERIENCING DUE TO BEING SHORT
STAFFED. AND EVEN THOUGH IT IS
ACTIVELY TRYING TO RECRUIT
PEOPLE AND IMPROVE THEIR,
ENFORCING MECHANISMS, THIS
PROCESS WILL TAKE TIME, MOST
LIKELY YEARS, AND WE CANNOT
ALLOW IT ANYMORE TO NEGATIVELY
AFFECT THE LIVES OF MANY
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR RESPECTIVE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN VICTIM
OF EXPLOITATION AND WAGE THEFT.
THAT IS WHY I'M HERE IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY, TO PROVIDING MY FULL
SUPPORT FOR AB 2135, AS IT WILL
ENSURE ENOUGH TIME TO PROVIDE
JUSTICE FOR ALL EMPLOYEES WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISH TO STEP
FORWARD AND EXPRESS NAME,
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MIKE WEST, ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND SUPPORT.
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ELMER LAZARD, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION, IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MARTIN VENDIOLA, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS. THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS, AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
JOHN HERSHEY, PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL 447 HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. WE'LL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION. I KNOW THERE
WAS SOME REGISTERED OPPOSITION
ON THE BILL. DO WE HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS. SCOTT. GOVERNOR, BEHALF
OF THE CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION, WERE THE LARGEST
UNION SIGNATORY BUILDERS IN THE
STATE. WE HAVE A VESTED INTEREST
IN ENSURING WORKERS ARE PAID.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IS
WE'RE NOT IDENTIFYING WHAT THE
ACTUAL IMPEDIMENTS ARE. IF DLSS
ISN'T DOING IT IN 18 MONTHS,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO IT IN 24
MONTHS. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO
IT IN 42 MONTHS. IT DOESN'T
CHANGE THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM IS
DLSS GOING AFTER THE CONTROLLING
EMPLOYER? I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS
THE DATA FROM DLSS AND HOW CAN
WE ACTUALLY FIX IT? BECAUSE
EXTENDING THE TIME IS SIMPLY
GOING TO DELAY HOW OFTEN, HOW
LONG IT TAKES TO GET WORKERS
PAID. AND FRANKLY, FOR OUR LARGE
MEMBERS, THEY CAN HOLD ON TO
THIS. THE EXTRA TIME DOESN'T
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE. BUT IF
YOU'RE A SMALL CONTRACTOR OR
SUBCONTRACTOR CARRYING THAT
EXTRA LIABILITY IS GOING TO
PRECLUDE YOU FROM BIDDING. SO AS
WE TALK ABOUT DIVERSIFYING THE
SUBCONTRACT AND WORKERS ON OUR
JOB SITES, YOU'RE SIMPLY MAKING
IT MORE DIFFICULT TO DO SO. SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT WITNESS
. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS, RICHARD MARKUSON FOR
THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION. WE
AGREE WITH THE PREVIOUS WITNESS.
OUR MEMBERS CERTAINLY DO NOT
COUNTENANCE A SHORT PAY DENIAL
OF BENEFITS AND NOT TAKING CARE
OF THEIR EMPLOYEES. HOWEVER,
MAKING THESE AGGRIEVED EMPLOYEES
WAIT LONGER FOR COMPENSATION IS
NOT THE ANSWER. SOMETHING NEEDS
TO HAPPEN AT DLSE TO PROVIDE
THEM THE ADEQUATE STAFF AND THE
ABILITY TO INVESTIGATE THESE
CASES AND RESOLVE THEM AND GET
THE AGGRIEVED EMPLOYEES PAID.
NOT WAITING LONGER. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WISHES TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION NAME AND AFFILIATION,
PLEASE? THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
NAOMI PIDGEON, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SUBCONTRACTORS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THAT CONCLUDES
TESTIMONY, SENATOR ROSSOW, ANY
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS BEFORE WE
GO BACK TO THE AUTHOR? YEAH,
JUST THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I WAS
VERY IMPRESSED WITH THE
WITNESSES WHO SPOKE THE Kò
WITNESSES WHO SPOKE, I THINK
THEY'RE RIGHT ON. I'M JUST
WONDERING. AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER NOW, IF THE ISSUES RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION WHO APPEARED
TO BE ON, YOU KNOW, THE
UNIONIZED SIDE OF EMPLOYERS, IF
THE ISSUE THEY RAISE COULD
SOMEHOW BE ADDRESSED. BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT'S NOT YOUR INTENTION
TO HURT SMALL. ESPECIALLY
UNIONIZED CONTRACTORS. SO IF
THERE IS GREAT, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THAT WOULD BE THE
IDEAL. YEAH. I MEAN, I THINK
WITH THEIR, SPEAKING TO IS THAT
IF YOU HAVE A CHARGE AGAINST YOU
, THEN IT CAN MEAN THAT YOU
CAN'T BID ON FUTURE CONTRACTS.
SO I THINK, WE HOPE THAT PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE CHARGES OF WAGE THEFT
AGAINST THEM. AND, AND THIS IS A
WAY FOR US TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
HOLDING BAD ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE,
WE HAVE ALREADY WORKED WITH THE
OPPOSITION. UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO BRING THEM TO NOT
OPPOSE, BUT WE'VE MADE SOME
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. AND I THINK IT GOES A
LONG WAY TO ADDRESSING CONCERNS.
THERE WAS A CONCERN THAT IT
WOULD BE OPEN ENDED AND YOU
COULD EXTEND CASES FOREVER AND
EVER. WE'RE MAKING THAT
AMENDMENT TODAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S CLEAR AND HAVE
LIMITED IT TO 24 MONTHS. THE
REALITY IS, THAT DLSS IS NOT
COMPLETING ALL OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS, AND PEOPLE WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED WAGE THEFT AND
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET ARE
GETTING NO RESOLUTION BECAUSE OF
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN RIGHT.
THEY'VE MOVED THE CASES FORWARD.
WE'VE HEARD FROM SOMEONE WHO
DOES THIS EVERY DAY, AND WE KNOW
THAT IF, IF IN GOOD FAITH,
PEOPLE ARE MOVING CASES FORWARD,
THAT THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE IT
CLOSED JUST BECAUSE THEY
REACHED, YOU KNOW, THE DEADLINE,
THEY SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PUSH A LITTLE BIT HARDER AND
GET A LITTLE EXTRA TIME TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT, MAKE SURE
THEIR CASE IS RESOLVED. WE'RE
ALWAYS HAPPY TO HEAR, YOU KNOW,
LANGUAGE SUGGESTIONS FROM
OPPOSITION. WE HAVEN'T HEARD ONE
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND HAPPY TO CONSIDER IT
IF IT COMES UP. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND ALL OF THE
SUPPORTERS, IT'S STILL BOGGLES
THE MIND THAT IN A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA WITH SO MUCH WEALTH,
THAT SO MANY WORKERS WOULD HAVE
THEIR WAGES STOLEN OR DEPRIVED
OF THEM. SO I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU, YEAH, I
THINK IT'S PROBABLY LESS ABOUT
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE THAT COULD
SOLVE THE ISSUE AND MORE ABOUT
THIS, YOU KNOW, UNDERLYING ISSUE
OF, WHICH HAS COME UP IN MANY
HEARINGS, INCLUDING
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS OF LATE,
ABOUT OUR ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS
AND AGENCIES, STAFFING UP AND
MOVING MUCH MORE QUICKLY THAN
THEY ARE. AND I THINK PEOPLE ARE
WORKING HARD AT THAT IN, YOU
KNOW, CONCURRENTLY IN A SORT OF
A PARALLEL EFFORT THROUGH AUDITS
AND, AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
TRYING TO CLOSE THAT GAP, BUT I
THINK IN THE MEANTIME, THIS IS
THIS IS A GOOD BILL IN THE SENSE
THAT IF YOU VIEW IT AS GOING
HAND IN HAND WITH THE REFORMS
AND THE HIRING AND THINGS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO COMPLEMENT
IT, THEN IT'S OKAY, AND YOU
CAN'T DO ALL THAT WITH ONE BILL
ANYWAY. SO OF COURSE I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL AS WELL,
AND, SENATOR DURAZZO HAS OFFERED
A MOTION, SO WE'LL LET YOU CLOSE
AND WE'LL GET THE VOTES THAT WE
CAN ON THE BILL RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS TODAY,
AND YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY, LIKE
YOU SAID, WE CAN'T DO EVERYTHING
IN ONE BILL. WE ARE ON A
SEPARATE TRACK ALSO REACHING OUT
TO DLSS JUST TO SEE, TO GET TO
KIND OF THE ROOT OF THE ISSUE
AND SEE IF THERE ARE WAYS THAT
THINGS CAN BE TRIAGED IN THE
INTERIM WHILE THEY ARE WORKING
ON STAFFING UP MORE. BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, WE DON'T WANT THIS
TO GO ANY SLOWER EITHER, RIGHT?
PEOPLE NEED MONEY IN THEIR
POCKETS IF THEY'VE EXPERIENCED
WAGE THEFT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND SO, SO WE HOPE
THAT THERE CAN BE OTHER CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THIS AS
WELL. BUT WE THINK THAT, LIKE
YOU SAID IN THE INTERIM, THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED. SO APPRECIATE AND I
VOTE WHEN YOU ALL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND WE CAN GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
ROLL OF THOSE PRESENT ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. THE MOTION IS
Dð. PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR CORTEZ Ã CORTEZ I WILK
DURAZO DURAZO I GONZALEZ. LAIRD
ALL RIGHT. THAT IS A 2 TO 0.
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFIED AND THE EXCELLENT
POINTS THEY MADE ON BOTH SIDES.
THANK YOU, WE YEAH, WE ARE GOING
TO PAUSE FOR JUST A MOMENT
BEFORE WE INVITE THE NEXT AUTHOR
UP, WHILE SENATOR DURAZO IS
HERE, EVERYBODY'S MOVING AROUND,
TO BUDGET COMMITTEES AND OTHER
PLACES TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
LIFT THE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND THEN THE ADDITIONAL
BILLS, AS APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
SENATOR DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE.
GONZALEZ. CALENDAR ON CALL. YEAH
CAN WE, CAN WE GET SENATOR
DURAZZO? CAN WE LIFT THE CALL ON
THOSE BILLS? SENATOR DURAZZO WAS
NOT PRESENT FOR EARLIER ON FILE
ITEM ONE ONE, AB 1976. HANEY THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AS THE CHAIR IS
VOTING AYE, SENATOR WILK SEN.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. OKAY. THAT THREE ZERO
ON CALL ON FILE ITEM TWO, AB
2182 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY. THE
CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR.
WILK. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE
GONZALEZ ALSO THREE ZERO ON
CALL. OKAY. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
MOTION. I'M REMINDED THAT WE
WERE UNABLE TO GET A MOTION ON
FILE ITEM THREE EARLIER, AS ONLY
THE CHAIR WAS PRESENT. SENATOR
DURAZZO, ALL RIGHT. SENATOR ALSO
MOVES FILE ITEM THREE, AB 1997,
AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
ROLL ON THAT ON AB 1997, THE
MOTION IS Dð PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR CORTEZ. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. SENATOR WILK DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE. GONZALEZ. LAIRD
ALL RIGHT. TWO ZERO ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. SO WE WILL CONTINUE NOW
WITH PRESENTATIONS. IT LOOKS
LIKE, SOME OR ORTEGA IS HERE AND
PREPARED, YOU MAY COME FORWARD
AND PRESENT IF YOU'RE READY ON
FILE ITEM TEN AB 2705. WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2705,
WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS TIME TO RECOVER
UNPAID WAGES FOR WORKERS WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO WAGE THEFT ON PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS. AS WE JUST
HEARD, WE KNOW THAT WAGE THEFT
IN THE DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES IS A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM, ESPECIALLY
IN THE CONSTRUCTION AREA. UNDER
EXISTING LAW, WHEN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER FINDS A VIOLATION
OF PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENT
ON A PROJECT, THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS 18 MONTHS TO
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT OF FINES
AND PENALTIES TO BE ASSESSED,
BUT ONLY SIX MONTHS TO SUE THE
COMPANY THAT BONDED THE PROJECT.
THIS INCONSISTENCY IN THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS MEANS
THAT THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
COULD BE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
ASSESSMENT AND RUN OUT OF TIME
TO RECOVER THE WAGES OWED TO THE
WORKERS FROM THE BONDING
COMPANY. WORKERS SHOULD NOT
SUFFER A POTENTIAL SIGNIFICANT
LOSS IN WAGES DUE TO
UNINTENTIONAL INCONSISTENCY IN
THE LAW. WHEN APPROPRIATE, I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE AND I DO NOT HAVE ANY
WITNESSES TODAY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, NO SUPPORT WITNESSES,
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS SUPPORT? NAME
AND AFFILIATION ONLY? MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, MIKE WEST, ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MATT CREMEANS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS. STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MARTIN VENDIOLA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS, THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS,
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THAT
CONCLUDES ALL. SUPPORT
WITNESSES. WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION. NOW, I'M NOT CLEAR
THAT WE HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS OR I'LL START. YOU CAN
DO THAT. ALL RIGHT. YOU'LL HAVE
A CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT GAVIN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION, AS WITH
THE PRIOR BILL, THIS RAISES KIND
OF TWO QUESTIONS. HOW OFTEN IS
DLSC GOING AFTER PAYMENT BONDS,
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHY ON
EARTH ARE THEY DOING THAT? YOU
HAVE A CONTROLLING EMPLOYER ON
PUBLIC WORKS JOBS. WE GET PAID
EXPONENTIALLY QUICKER THAN SUING
A BONDING COMPANY. AGAIN WE HAVE
TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON AT DLSC
BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T BENEFIT
WORKERS. IT SLOWS DOWN THE
PROCESS. AND THIS IS A BAND AID
THAT REALLY DOESN'T HELP ANYONE.
SO FOR THESE REASONS, WE ARE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE CAN HAVE ONE MORE TWO MINUTE
WITNESS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. RICHARD
MARKUSON FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. WE'VE HAD MIXED
RESPONSES FROM OUR SURETIES
ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
BOND FOR THIS EXTENDED PERIOD OF
TIME. THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED ABOUT IS FOR
SMALLER EMPLOYEES, THEIR ABILITY
TO PURCHASE A BOND THAT WILL NOW
BE EXTENDED FOR THREE TIMES THE
INITIAL PERIOD OF TIME, IS GOING
TO MAKE IT A CHALLENGE, I THINK,
FOR MANY SMALL CONTRACTORS WHO
ARE TRYING TO BREAK INTO THE
PUBLIC WORKS FIELD AND THEY WILL
BE UNABLE TO COMPETE, AND FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE HAVE VERY
STRONG CONCERNS AND OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WE'RE NOW OPEN
FOR NAME AFFILIATION AND OPPOSE.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO DO THAT. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
NAOMI PADRON, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN SUBCONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND SENATOR, ALSO,
ANY COMMENTS? ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
GO BACK TO THE AUTHOR FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE, AND THEN
WE'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
OKAY. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. AND SENATOR, ARE YOU
WILLING TO MAKE THE MOTION
MOTION BY DURAZZO. AND WE'LL
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM TEN.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR CORTEZ, A CORTEZ I WILK
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I GONZALEZ.
LAIRD TWO ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. AND
AGAIN, THANK YOU TO WITNESSES
FOR TESTIFYING. WE ARE IN NEED
OF AN AUTHOR. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS. AND
WE WILL RESUME. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT. I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE COMMITTEE BACK TO
ORDER. I THINK WE'RE CLOSE
ENOUGH TO FIVE MINUTES,
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A FULL PRESENTATION HERE.
AND, ANYBODY ABSENT, HOPEFULLY
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK
HERE. I KNOW THERE'S PLENTY OF
WIRED SOUND AROUND THE BUILDING
HERE, SO PLEASE COME ON BACK TO
SENATE LABOR, PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND RETIREMENT COMMITTEE. IF YOU
HAVE BUSINESS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE. AND WE DO HAVE
ASSEMBLYMAN MAIENSCHEIN HERE ON
AB 2971, FILE ITEM 13, AND YOU
CAN PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. MEMBER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS
RUNNING SMOOTHLY FROM SERVING
MEALS TO CLEANING CLASSROOMS.
UNFORTUNATELY, MANY SCHOOLS ARE
FACING STAFFING SHORTAGES, WHICH
MAKES IT HARDER TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND MAINTAIN A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT. CURRENTLY, THERE
ARE NO CLEAR GUIDELINES ON HOW
MANY STAFF MEMBERS SCHOOLS
ACTUALLY NEED. THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC HAS MADE THESE ISSUES
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT. AB 2971
WILL HELP US HAVE BETTER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW MANY
STAFF MEMBERS SCHOOLS NEED TO
KEEP STUDENTS SAFE AND
SUPPORTED. IT'S AN IMPORTANT
STEP TOWARDS CREATING A STRONGER
AND MORE RESILIENT EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS TRISTAN BROWN, THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF CFT, A
UNION OF EDUCATORS, AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS. THANK
YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU AND
WELCOME. AND YOU HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, TRISTAN
BROWN, CFT, UNION OF EDUCATORS
AND CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS, AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER POINTS OUT,
THIS BILL COMES FROM OUR
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WHO
DO, THEIR CHIEF JOB IS MAKING
SURE THAT ALL OF OUR SCHOOL
FACILITIES HAS HEALTH. AND
SAFETY IS NUMBER ONE FOR OUR
STUDENTS, NOT JUST IN
TRANSPORTATION AND FOOD SERVICE,
BUT ALSO CUSTODIAL AND OTHER
SERVICES, THIS BILL IS ADDING
REPRESENTATION FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, CLASSIFIED TO AN
EXISTING WORK GROUP THAT WAS
PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR TO CREATE A WORK GROUP THAT
WOULD EXAMINE WHAT WORK RATIOS
SHOULD BE. IN A PERFECT WORLD,
THIS WAS BORN OUT OF THE COVID
19 PANDEMIC, WHEN, AS EDUCATION
STAKEHOLDERS WERE COMING
TOGETHER TO TRY TO FIND OUT HOW
WE SHOULD REOPEN SCHOOLS AGAIN.
FOR STUDENTS, HEALTH AND SAFETY
IS PRIORITY NUMBER ONE TALKS
ABOUT HOW CUSTODIANS COULD WIPE
DOWN HIGH TOUCH FREQUENCY AREAS
LIKE DOORKNOBS AND BANISTERS
WERE PART OF THE DISCUSSION.
QUICKLY, THE JOKE ABOUT PAINTING
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE WHERE AS
SOON AS YOU'RE DONE, YOU HAVE TO
TURN AROUND AND START ALL OVER
AGAIN, WAS MADE, AND WE REALIZED
WE WEREN'T QUITE SURE WHAT THE
RIGHT RATIO OF CUSTODIANS TO
SQUARE FEET AND FACILITIES WOULD
BE TO MAINTAIN A HIGH LEVEL OF
SAFETY FOR STUDENTS. THUS, THE
WORK GROUP WAS BORN, WE
UNFORTUNATELY LEFT OUT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIDE OF
THINGS, AND THEY HAVE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH THEIR
POPULATIONS AND THEIR
FACILITIES. THEY DESERVE A SEAT
AT THIS TABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS IN COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
HEALTH AND SAFETY IS NUMBER ONE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD THIS DOES
NOT IN ANY WAY HAVE ANY FORCE OF
LAW AS TO THE ACTUAL HIRING
PRACTICES OF A DISTRICT THAT IS
STILL LEFT UP TO BUDGETS,
BARGAINING, AND BEST INTENTIONS.
SO THESE ARE GOOD GUIDELINES
THAT WE HOPE WILL EXIST IN THE
WORLD. AND PROVIDE A NORTH STAR
FOR US TO AIM TO MAKE SURE ALL
STUDENTS ARE SAFE IN THEIR
FACILITIES. AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS A
SUPPORT POSITION WE CAN TAKE?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT
MATT BROD HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. OTHERS BRIAN
MIRAMONTES WITH ASK ME
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, SEEING NO
OTHERS, WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION. IS THERE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS HERE? SEEING
NONE. IS THERE ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION NAME AND
AFFILIATION? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NO ONE COME
FORWARD, WE ORDINARILY COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT,
THAT WOULD BE THE CHAIR ONLY AT
THIS POINT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS, YOU MAY, AND THEN WE
WILL, I ASSURE YOU, TAKE THE
BILL UP AS SOON AS WE CAN GET A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. WELL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
AND AGAIN, THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES. ALL RIGHT. SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TRY TO GET THE WORD
OUT THAT WE NEED AUTHORS IN
SENATE LABOR, PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND RETIREMENT HERE IN,
COMMITTEE ROOM 2200. WE HAVE
FOUR BILLS LEFT THAT REQUIRE
HEARING PRESENTATION THAT
HAVEN'T ALREADY BEEN ACTED UPON
ON CONSENT OR OTHERWISE HEARD.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE
AUTHORS HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. NOW ALL FOUR, PREFERABLY.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE JUST GOING TO
TURN THE MICROPHONES OFF HERE
AND INFORMALLY RECESS. I'M GOING
TO ASK THE ASSISTANT TO JUST
TIME THAT FOR TWO MINUTES. AND
IF WE HAVE TO RECESS LONGER THAN
THAT, I'LL GAVEL US DOWN AND LET
EVERYBODY KNOW. BUT LET'S JUST
TAKE A TWO MINUTE INFORMAL
BREAK. THANK YOU.
YEAH. JUST FOR THE SAKE OF
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO MOVE AROUND.
AND FOR THE AUDIO SYSTEM, I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND. OH! SAVED
BY THE BELL. NO PROBLEM. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
AND LIFT THE CALL WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR AUTHORS, AND THAT'LL
HELP ALL OF US, I THINK, TO AT
LEAST GET ON THE RECORD AS MUCH
AS WE CAN HERE. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR SOMEONE TO PRESENT.
SO AS THE ASSISTANT TO DO THAT
NOW, STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND MOVING THROUGH,
WHATEVER BILLS ARE APPROPRIATE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. FIVE ZERO. WE'LL KEEP
IT ON CALL. WE CAN BE OUT. IT'S
OUT IF WE LIKE IT. SAY OH, IT IS
OUT. I'M SORRY. THANK YOU.
THINKING ABOUT, A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE WITH MORE MEMBERS ON
IT. SORRY ABOUT THAT. ALL RIGHT.
FIVE ZERO THAT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT. THANK YOU.
PLEASE CONTINUE STARTING AT THE
TOP OF THE FILE. FILE ORDER ITEM
ONE. MOTION IS Dð. PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THAT'S AB 1976.
HANEY, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR WILK, SENATOR
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I 401 KHÓ. ALL
RIGHT. THAT IS NOW AT FOUR ZERO.
LEAVE IT ON CALL ON FILE ITEM
TWO. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
THE CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK, SENATOR GONZALEZ GONZALEZ,
I THAT IS ALSO FOUR ZERO. AND
WE'LL KEEP IT ON CALL. ITEM
NUMBER THREE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CHAIR IS
VOTING AYE. SENATOR WILK,
SENATOR GONZALEZ, SENATOR LAIRD.
SO WE'RE AT 301. ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S IT. THREE ZERO. AND WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL ON ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. THE CHAIR IS VOTING
AYE. SENATOR WILK, SENATOR
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE SENATOR
LAIRD, THAT IS NOW AT THREE
ZERO. AND WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL
. JUMPING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN. THAT'S AB 2705 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY, THE CHAIR IS VOTING
AYE. SENATOR WILK, SENATOR
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE. SENATOR
LAIRD, THAT IS NOW AT THREE
ZERO, AND WE'LL LEAVE IT AT
CALL. OKAY LET'S GET A MOTION
13. OH, RIGHT ON FILE ITEM 13.
WE DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS
PRESENT FOR A MOTION, FILE ITEM
13, THE AUTHOR IS, MAIENSCHEIN.
WE JUST HEARD THAT BILL. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO MAKE A MOTION ON THAT? YES
ALL RIGHT. MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ. SO WE'LL CALL THE
ROLL, PLEASE, ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER 13. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR CORTEZ.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. WILK. DURAZO
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. LAIRD
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILLS AT TWO
ZERO AND WE WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. AND I SEE THAT SOME MEMBER
VALENCIA IS PRESENT, PLEASE COME
FORWARD, ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON AB
3025 FILE OUR FILE ITEM 14, AND
YOU MAY PRESENT WHEN READY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND GOOD MORNING TO THE MEMBERS,
AB 3025 ESTABLISHES A PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RECEIVE THEIR NEGOTIATED
RETIREMENT BENEFITS, EVEN IF
CERTAIN COMPENSATION IS
DISALLOWED. DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION UNDERMINES THE
PROMISE OF A SECURE RETIREMENT
AND JEOPARDIZES THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR COUNTY RETIREMENT SYSTEMS.
CURRENTLY, COUNTY EMPLOYEES AND
RETIREES BEAR THE BRUNT OF THESE
READJUSTMENTS, HAVING TO PAY
BACK RETIREMENT SYSTEMS FOR
OVERPAYMENTS DESPITE THE
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVES NEGOTIATING A
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION ONLY
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES ARE
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
REPAYMENT PROCEDURES AND
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION CASES BY
IMPLEMENTING A 20% PENALTY ON
EMPLOYERS IN CASES OF DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION, THE BURDEN OF THE
READJUSTMENT TO BENEFITS Tð
BENEFITS IS MORE BALANCED
BETWEEN EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE.
THESE PENALTIES REFLECT
RETIREMENT SYSTEM STANDARDS
FOUND IN CALPERS AND CALSTRS,
AND WITH ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
ON THIS BILL IS DOUG SUBURBS,
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS, AND
JENNIFER ROWE, ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE. ORANGE COUNTY, PLEASE,
MR. SILVER, PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES. START WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
SENATOR, DOUG SUPERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS, OR CPF, IS PLEASED
TO CO-SPONSOR AB 3025. I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD,
AS NOTED BY THE AUTHOR, THIS
MEASURE WILL CREATE A CLEAR
PROCESS TO ADDRESS DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION IN COUNTY EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS IDENTIFIED ON
OR AFTER JANUARY ONE, 2024. THE
STRUCTURE OF THIS MEASURE IS
SIMILAR TO POLICIES ENACTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION IN
CALPERS AND CALSTRS. DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION IS WHEN A PAY ITEM
IS INCLUDED IN AN EMPLOYEE'S
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION, IS
SUBSEQUENTLY DETERMINED TO BE
NON PENSIONABLE THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THE EMPLOYEE. FOR ACTIVE
MEMBERS, THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM
WILL NOTIFY THE EMPLOYER TO STOP
REPORTING ON THE ITEM, AND
OFTENTIMES THE RECOGNIZED
EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVE AND THE
EMPLOYER CAN GO BACK TO THE
TABLE TO BARGAIN AND SORT THE
DIFFERENCE AND EITHER CORRECT
THE PAY ITEM OR IDENTIFY A NEW
OPPORTUNITY TO, MAKE THE
EMPLOYEES WHOLE. HOWEVER, FOR A
RETIREE, WHEN DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION IS IDENTIFIED, THE
RETIREE GETS A NOTICE THAT THEY
MAY OWE THOUSANDS OR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
OVERPAYMENT AND HAVE THEIR
RETIREMENT ALLOWANCE PERMANENTLY
REDUCED. FOR A FIREFIGHTER
LIVING ON A FIXED INCOME, THE
NOTICE THEY MAY OWE THAT AMOUNT
OF MONEY, AND IT WILL BE, OWE
MONEY BACK TO THE SYSTEM AND
THAT THAT ALLOWANCE WILL BE
REDUCED IN PERPETUITY CAN BE
DEVASTATING, PARTICULARLY GIVEN
THE PHYSICAL NATURE OF
FIREFIGHTING PROFESSION, IT'S
UNLIKELY THAT THAT FIREFIGHTER
WILL BE ABLE TO GO BACK TO WORK
AFTER RETIREMENT. AB 30225
ESTABLISHES A CLEAR PROCESS TO
PROVIDE A MODEST MITIGATION ON
THE IMPACT BY REQUIRING THE
EMPLOYER TO COVER THE
OVERPAYMENT AND THE RETIREE TO
RECEIVE AN ACTUARILY ESTIMATED
PAYMENT. TO REDUCE THE IMPACT OF
THE REDUCED ALLOWANCE. THIS DOES
NOT KEEP THE RETIREE WHOLE, BUT
IT IS NECESSARY PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE THAT RETIREES DO NOT HOLD
100% OF THE OBLIGATION WHEN
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION OCCURS.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY, DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER SUPPORT WITNESS? YES.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. EXCUSE ME, JENNIFER
ROWE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE, ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD. WE'RE PLEASED TO BE A
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 3025 TO HELP
WHAT WE BELIEVE, WRITES A
SIGNIFICANT WRONG WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR RETIREES, OUR MEMBERS WHO
WORKED THEIR CAREERS IN HIGH
PROFILE UNITS SUCH AS HOMICIDE,
BOMB SQUAD OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS, CANINES AND OTHER
SPECIALIZED UNITS WITHIN THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICES GAVE
UP VALUABLE FAMILY TIME DURING
EVENINGS, HOLIDAYS AND WEEKENDS
IN ORDER TO REMAIN AVAILABLE TO
IMMEDIATELY RESPOND WHEN CALLED
UPON. THESE MEN AND WOMEN DID
THEIR JOB AS THEY WERE REQUIRED
AND REQUESTED, AND IN RETURN
THEY WERE PROMISED A GUARANTEED
WAGE AND A GUARANTEED INCOME IN
RETIREMENT. TO NOW BE TOLD BY
THEIR RETIREMENT SYSTEM. THERE'S
A MISTAKE IN THEIR CALCULATION,
AND THIS MISTAKE IS TO BE BORNE
BY THEM, BY NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN IS SIMPLY AN INJUSTICE. THE
EMPLOYEES ARE BASICALLY BEING
TOLD NOW THAT THEY WORKED FOR A
DISCOUNT, THE EMPLOYER
ULTIMATELY GETS THE BENEFIT OF
THIS BARGAIN. HUNDREDS, IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF RETIREES ARE LOSING
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
RETIREMENT. AS STATED BY MR.
SUBERS, NOT ONLY FROM CLAWBACKS
BUT ON THE GO FORWARD. IT'S
SIMPLY NOT RIGHT. AND FOR THESE
REASONS, WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 3025. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WE CAN NOW TAKE
SUPPORT POSITIONS, NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBER SARA FLOCKS,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, IN
SUPPORT BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH
ACP CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS PAT MORAN WITH
AARON REED AND ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND THE
RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE. IS THERE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS SEEING NO ONE
COME FORWARD? IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
? HAVING HEARD THE PRESENTATION
ON THE BILL, YOU MAY COME
FORWARD. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS TANISHA BOATNER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES,
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION, THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA, AND THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION WISHING TO
COME FORWARD, WE WILL THEN COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THE BILL? ALL
RIGHT, SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
OFFERED TO MOVE, THE
RECOMMENDATION ON THE BILL. AND
BEFORE WE TAKE A ROLL CALL, I
WANT TO GIVE THE AUTHOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. THANK YOU,
IT'S A TWO PARTY PROCESS, RIGHT.
AND I THINK IF THERE IS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE ERROR, A
FINANCIAL MISCALCULATION THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE, THAT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY NEEDS TO BE
SHARED AS WELL. SO THANK YOU.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES
VOTE. OKAY. WELL, THANK YOU.
AND, WE WILL ASK THE ASSISTANT
TO TAKE A ROLL CALL, VOTE AT
THIS TIME ON THE MOTION BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ, AND RESTATE
THE MOTION, PLEASE, ON FILE ITEM
14 AB 3025. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR CORTEZ Ã
CORTEZ. AYE. WILK DURAZO.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. LAIRD
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE AT TWO ZERO,
BUT WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, I SAW
ANOTHER AUTHOR COME IN, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS THREE OF US, YOU
HAVE TWO FILE ITEMS. ITEM SEVEN
AND ITEM EIGHT. AB 2364 AND AB
2738. YOU MAY COME FORWARD AND
PRESENT IF READY AND I ASSUME
YOU'LL START WITH FILE ITEM
SEVEN. THAT IS, 2364 PROPERTY
SERVICE WORKER AB 2364 WILL BE
FIRST. 364 2364. THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT. PLEASE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. I WANT TO
START BY THANKING ALMA FOR HER
WORK AND THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS ON
THIS BILL, AB 2364 WOULD LIMIT,
DANGEROUSLY HIGH WORKLOADS IN
THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY FACED BY
THE AGING WORKFORCE.
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL CREATES
A SEVEN PERSON ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP PROPOSED
REGULATIONS ESTABLISHING
STANDARDS IN THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY. JANITORS ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. THEY ARE AT THE
FRONTLINES PROTECTING US FROM
DISEASES, WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK TO KEEP OUR GROCERY
STORES, OFFICE BUILDINGS AND
PUBLIC SPACES CLEAN AND
SANITIZED FOR US TO USE.
UNFORTUNATELY, OUR JANITORS ARE
EXPOSED TO FREQUENT INJURIES,
VIOLENCE, AND DISRESPECT IN THE
WORKPLACE. IN 2022, A STUDY BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS HIGHLIGHTED
THE BRUTAL CONDITIONS THAT
JANITORS FACE ON THE JOB,
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT ROUGHLY
ONE THIRD OF JANITORS IN
CALIFORNIA WERE INJURED ON THE
JOB LAST YEAR. THE STUDY ALSO
FOUND THAT ONE THIRD OF JANITORS
SAY THEY ARE HESITANT TO REPORT
INJURIES OUT OF FEAR OF
RETALIATION. MOST OF THESE
WORKERS ARE HARDWORKING
IMMIGRANT WOMEN. OUR MOTHERS,
GRANDMOTHERS AND SISTERS DESERVE
SAFE WORKING ENVIRONMENTS SO
THAT THEY CAN STAY HEALTHY AND
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES EVERY DAY. TODAY I HAVE
WITH ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY,
MARIA TRUJILLO, JANITOR FROM
OAKLAND, AND KEVIN ROUX,
RESEARCHER AT THE UC BERKELEY
CENTER FOR OCCUPATIONAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH, HERE TO
TRANSLATE FOR MARIA IS MY STAFF,
JOSE MEDINA, THANK YOU, GO AHEAD
AND HAVE THE WITNESSES COME
FORWARD. IT LOOKS LIKE THE
WITNESS THAT'S GOING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE TRANSLATION
WILL BE FIRST. AND GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN. I THINK WE MET
RECENTLY. THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED. YOU'LL HAVE FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL. SO YOU HAVE A
COUPLE MINUTES TO SPEAK, AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES
FOR TRANSLATION. THANK YOU.
BUENOS DIAS, SENADOR CORTEZ.
GRACIAS SONADORAS Y SENADORES.
GRACIAS POR ESTA OPORTUNIDAD
PARA PODER EXPRESAR ME. MY NAME
IS MARIA TRUJILLO. TRABAJADO POR
VEINTICUATRO ANOS EN LA
INDUSTRIA DE LA LIMPIEZA IN
OAKLAND. EMIGRA A ESTE PAIS HACE
CÁC PORTANTINO'S CUANDO ME
ESPOSO OBTUVO LA RESIDENCIA CON
LA AMNISTIA DE LOS HØI SOY UNA
ORGULLOSA MADRE DE CUATRO HIJOS
Y ABUELA DE SIETE TODOS
MARAVILLOSOS COMO INMIGRANTE EN
ESTE PAIS, ENFRENTADO MUCHOS
DESAFIOS, PERO SIEMPRE HA SIDO
TENAZ A TRABAJADO DURO PARA
MEJORAR LA VIDA DE MI FAMILIA AL
IGUAL C¯ MUCHOS OTROS MADRES
TRABAJADORES JANITORS COMO YO
CON BAJOS SALARIOS SUPREMOS DE
PRIMERA MANO. LOS IMPACTOS
NEGATIVOS DE LA AVARICIA DE LAS
COMPANIAS TECNOLOGICAS LOS
EMPLEADORES ESTE UTILIZANDO EL
PRETEXTO DE C¯ DE LAS VACANTS DE
OFICINAS PARA JUSTIFICAR LA
REDUCCION DE ORTEZ Y EL AUMENTO
DE LA CARGA DE TRABAJO A NIVELES
PELIGROSOS DEJANDO A LOS
TRABAJADORES INMIGRANTES CON
LESIONS AND DOLORES CRONICAS EN
SUS CUERPOS. POR ESO, C¯
NECESITAN RAMOS QUÊ USTEDES
APOYAN LA PROPUESTA DE LEY A
2370 CUATRO PARA PODER PONER FIN
A LA EXPLOITATION Y EL ABUSO DE
LOS TRABAJADORES DE LIMPIEZA DE
DIA. VEMOS COMO A NUESTROS
COMPANEROS. LES HORAS Þ SON
DESPEDIDO DE SUS TRABAJOS DE
ELLOS A LA DERIVA SIN SALARIO NI
SEGURO MÉDICO. A MEDIDA C¯ LOS
RECORTES CONTINUAN LOS
TRABAJADORES QUÊ SE QUEDAN SE
VEN OBLIGADOS A LIMPIAR, MAS MAS
PISOS Þ LA MISMA CANTIDAD DE
OFICINAS, PERO CON MENOS
PERSONAL Y RECURSOS, YA NO
PODEMOS MAS CON LA SOBRECARGA DE
TRABAJO. UNO DE CADA TRES
LLANITOS HAN SIDO LASTIMADO EN
SU LUGAR DE TRABAJO, MAS DE LA
MITAD DE LOS TRABAJADORES DE LA
LIMPIEZA SUPREMOS DE DE DOLOR
SEVERO SIX DE CADA DÍAS JANITOR.
NECESITAMOS TOMAR MEDICAMENTOS
PARA EL DOLOR. MUCHOS DE MIS
COMPANEROS ESTAN EN EDAD DE
JUBILATION. AL IGUAL C¯ YO, PERO
NO PUEDEN DEJAR DE TRABAJAR
NUESTRA SALUD S¼ ESTÁ
DETERIORATE Y NECESITAMOS UN
MEJOR SEGURO MÉDICO ACCESO A
MEDICAMENTOS NECESARIOS. YOU'LL
HAVE TO WRAP UP. YOU'LL HAVE TO
STOP NOW. YOU'RE AT TWO MINUTES.
DOS MINUTOS. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU. MY NAME IS MARIA TRUJILLO,
AND I HAVE WORKED FOR 24 YEARS
IN THE CLEANING INDUSTRY IN
OAKLAND. I IMMIGRATED TO THIS
COUNTRY ALMOST 40 YEARS AGO WHEN
MY HUSBAND OBTAINED RESIDENCY
WITH THE AMNESTY OF THE 80S.
TODAY, I AM A PROUD MOTHER OF
FOUR CHILDREN AND GRANDMOTHER OF
SEVEN WONDERFUL GRANDCHILDREN.
AS AN IMMIGRANT TO THIS COUNTRY,
I HAVE FACED MANY CHALLENGES,
BUT I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN TENACIOUS
AND WORKED HARD TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF MY FAMILY. LIKE MANY
OTHER WORKING MOTHERS, JANITORS
IN A LOW WAGE INDUSTRY LIKE ME
SUFFER FIRSTHAND THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF TECH COMPANIES GREED.
EMPLOYERS ARE USING THE PRETEXT
OF OFFICE VACANCIES TO JUSTIFY
REDUCING HOURS AND INCREASING
WORKLOADS TO DANGEROUS LEVELS,
LEAVING MIGRANT WORKERS WITH
INJURIES AND CHRONIC PAIN ON
THEIR BODIES. THAT'S WHY WE NEED
YOU TO SUPPORT AB 2364 TO END
THE EXPLOITATION AND ABUSE OF
JANITORS. DAY AFTER DAY, WE SEE
HOW MY FELLOW JANITORS HAVE
THEIR HOURS REDUCED OR ARE FIRED
FROM THEIR JOBS, LEAVING THEM
ADRIFT WITHOUT SALARY OR HEALTH
INSURANCE. AS CUTS CONTINUE.
WORKERS WHO REMAIN ARE FORCED TO
CLEAN MORE FLOORS OR THE SAME
NUMBER OF OFFICES, BUT WITH
FEWER STAFF AND RESOURCES WE CAN
NO LONGER HANDLE DANGEROUSLY
HIGH WORKLOADS. 1 IN 3 JANITORS
HAVE BEEN INJURED IN THEIR
WORKPLACE. MORE THAN HALF OF US
CLEANING WORKERS SUFFER FROM
SEVERE PAIN. SIX OUT OF TEN
JANITORS NEED TO TAKE MEDICATION
TO RELIEVE PAIN. MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE OF RETIREMENT AGE
LIKE ME, BUT THEY CANNOT STOP
WORKING. OUR HEALTH IS
DETERIORATING AND WE NEED BETTER
HEALTH INSURANCE AND ACCESS TO
NECESSARY MEDICATIONS. CLEANING
WORKERS DESERVE RESPECT. WE ARE
THE ESSENTIAL IMMIGRANT
WORKFORCE TO KEEP THE ECONOMY
MOVING FORWARD. WE HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN THERE TO IMPROVE THE
ECONOMY WITH OUR CONTRIBUTIONS.
TODAY WE COME TO ASK THE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT OUR
DIGNITY. THANK YOU. AND I ASK
FOR YOU TO SUPPORT AB 2364. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. DID WE HAVE
ANOTHER LEAD WITNESS? YES.
PLEASE PROCEED. YOU HAVE A
COUPLE OF MINUTES. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS KEVIN RUE
AND I'M A RESEARCHER WITH UC
BERKELEY CENTER FOR OCCUPATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. ON THE
JANITOR WORKLOAD CALIFORNIA
JANITOR WORKLOAD STUDY, WHICH
WAS SUPPORTED BY THE COMMISSION
ON HEALTH AND SAFETY AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION. I'M HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE FOR AB 2364 BECAUSE I
BELIEVE, TO COMPREHEND AND
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS TO THE FULL
EXTENT OF THE CHALLENGES
JANITORS FACE. IT'S ESSENTIAL TO
LISTEN TO THEM DIRECTLY. OUR
STUDY, WHICH SURVEYED OVER 700
JANITORS, HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
SEVERE PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES OF HIGH
WORKLOAD BURDENS. HIGHER
WORKLOAD EXPOSURE INCREASED THE
RISK OF THESE REPORTED ADVERSE
HEALTH OUTCOMES, SUGGESTING AN
EXPOSURE RESPONSE RELATIONSHIP.
AND JUST TO NAME ONE EXAMPLE,
WORKERS EXPOSED TO HIGH
WORKLOADS WERE ASSOCIATED WITH
TWICE THE ODDS OF HAVING ANXIETY
OR DEPRESSION COMPARED TO THOSE
EXPOSED TO LOW WORKLOAD, WITH
SIMILAR ASSOCIATIONS FOUND FOR
OTHERS, SUCH AS WORK RELATED
INJURY INJURIES AND REGULARLY
MISSING WORK DUE TO PAIN, AND AS
WELL AS REGULARLY TAKING PAIN
MEDICATIONS. IN ADDITION,
JANITORIAL WORK HAS BEEN
CLASSIFIED IN OTHER LITERATURE
AS PRECARIOUS CHARACTER CAUSED
BY CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS LACK
OF CONTROL, BULLYING, AND
HARASSMENT, ALL OF WHICH HAS
SEEN TO REALLY AMPLIFY THESE
NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS. THESE
RESULTS OF OUR STUDY
CORROBORATED THOSE OF SIMILAR
STUDIES CONDUCTED BY WASHINGTON
STATE AND MINNESOTA, WHICH ALSO
FOUND HIGH PHYSICAL BURDEN OF
WORKLOAD AMONG THEIR JANITORS.
AND TOGETHER, THESE REALLY
EMPHASIZED THAT THE WORK RELATED
EXPOSURES OF JANITOR REQUIRE
MITIGATION, AND AB 2364 WOULD BE
CRITICAL STEP IN ACHIEVING THAT.
IT RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
THOSE PERFORMING THE WORK IN
SHAPING THEIR WORKING
CONDITIONS, EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSING THE COMPLEX ISSUES
FACED BY JANITORS REALLY
REQUIRES CONTINUOUS INPUT FROM
THE WORKERS, WHO THEMSELVES, AS
EMPLOYERS WHO DO NOT EXPERIENCE
THE DAILY REALITIES OF THE JOB,
ARE NOT NECESSARILY EQUIPPED TO
SET EFFECTIVE STANDARDS ALONE.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
STRUCTURED PROCESS TO ENSURE
ONGOING WORKER INPUT IS VITAL IN
AB 2364 AIMS TO ACHIEVE THAT.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE
STANDARDS FOR WORKERS ARE
PRACTICAL AND GENUINELY
BENEFICIAL. AFTER ALL, NEARLY
55% OF JANITORS SURVEYED ARE
OVER THE AGE OF 50 AND OLDER
INDIVIDUALS ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO ENERGY INJURIES
AND CHRONIC HEALTH ISSUES
ARISING FROM THEIR TASKS AND
JOBS. YOU'LL HAVE TO WRAP UP NOW
ULTIMATELY, BY FOSTERING
COLLABORATION AND DEVELOPING
SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE WORKER
PROTECTION IN A HEALTHY
WORKPLACE FOR ENVIRONMENTS, AB
2364 MARKS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
THAT, AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND TO THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS. THANK YOU AS WELL. THE
TWO MINUTE LIMIT. WE HAVE TO
ESTABLISH AT THE BEGINNING FOR
ALL SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION IN
ORDER TO BE FAIR. AND UNDER THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION, IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO KEEP THE
TIME LIMITS THE SAME. BUT WE GOT
EVERYBODY'S POINT LOUD AND
CLEAR. AND NOW WE'LL OPEN IT UP
TO SUPPORT WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
IDENTIFY BY NAME AND
AFFILIATION. THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT OF CMU CALIFORNIA, AS
WELL AS PRESIDENT OF SEIU US.
THANK YOU. YES. THANK YOU. SARA
FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. MY NAME IS TODA SILVA. I AM
JANITOR IN SACRAMENTO. I SUPPORT
. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
ARACELI CASTELLANOS, I AM
JANITOR, I SUPPORT. MY NAME IS
TERESA CARDOSO. I SAW JANITOR YO
APOYO. MY NAME IS ALICIA
MORALES. I'M A JANITOR, AND I'M
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME
IS ARACELI QUEZADA. I'M SUPPORT.
HI. MY NAME IS CATALINA ROCHA.
I'M A JANITOR HERE, AND I'M
SUPER. MY NAME IS ADRIN VELASCO.
I'M A JANITOR. I SUPPORT. SYLVIA
VILLALOBOS, JANITOR. YO, APOYO.
MY NAME IS ANDRÉS PEREZ. I'M A
SON OF A UNION MEMBER. AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT. MY NAME IS
TERESA GUILLEN. YO, MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA ALVAREZ. HERE WITH THE
JANITORS UNION. I SUPPORT RENE
BALADO FOR SEIU CALIFORNIA. AND
ME TOO FOR VOICES FOR PROGRESS.
CHRISTINA RAMIREZ WITH US WW IN
SUPPORT, ARACELI RUEDA WITH THE
US, WW IN SUPPORT OKAY. THANK
YOU ALL. IS THERE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YOU HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
SKYLER WONACOTT HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND OUR MEMBERS,
BOMA, CALIFORNIA, AND NAIOP,
CALIFORNIA, AND OVER 10,000
MEMBERS IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO AB 2364, AS AMENDED, AB 2364
PROPOSES SETTING UP A COUNCIL TO
REGULATE THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY, WHICH WE FEAR COULD
CREATE A REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT
SIMILAR TO THE PROBLEMATIC FAST
FOOD COUNCIL. THIS COULD RESULT
IN ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS PRIMARILY
AGAINST NONUNION EMPLOYERS,
LEADING TO MORE CLAIMS AND
LAWSUITS WITHOUT IMPROVING
WORKER CONDITIONS. THIS BILL'S
CRITERIA FOR DEFINING A
REASONABLE WORKLOAD ARE OVERLY
SIMPLISTIC AND FAIL TO CAPTURE
THE COMPLEXITIES OF JANITORIAL
WORK. ADDITIONALLY, THE PROPOSED
COUNCIL COMPOSITION REDUCES
MANAGEMENT, REPRESENTATION,
POTENTIALLY INCREASING COSTS AND
REDUCING OPERATIONAL FLEXIBILITY
FOR EMPLOYERS. AB 2364 IMPOSES
EXCESSIVE TRAINING COSTS ON
EMPLOYERS, PARTICULARLY SMALL
BUSINESSES. IT MANDATES MORE
COSTLY HARASSMENT TRAINING
PROGRAMS, DISPROPORTIONATE TO
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS. THE
CURRENT $65 PER EMPLOYEE CHARGE
UNDER LABOR CODE 1420 ADEQUATELY
COVERS SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING.
THIS BILL COULD LEAD TO JOB
LOSSES AS BUSINESSES MAY TURN TO
AUTOMATED AUTOMATED AUTOMATION
TO OFFSET INCREASED COSTS. IT
WILL ALSO DRIVE UP COSTS FOR
CLEANING STATE OWNED BUILDINGS,
INCLUDING SCHOOLS. RECENT SEIU
AGREEMENTS ALREADY ADDRESS
WORKLOAD DISPUTES, MAKING THIS
BILL UNNECESSARY. Kò, THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE'S LABOR HEAVY
COMPOSITION, LACKS BALANCED
REPRESENTATION, AND THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE IS
REDUNDANT, GIVING CAL OSHA'S
RULE. CALIFORNIA FACES SOME OF
THE HIGHEST OFFICE VACANCY RATES
IN THE NATION, AND AB 2364 WOULD
ONLY WORSEN THE SITUATION,
LEADING TO MORE BLIGHTED
PROPERTIES AND ECONOMIC DECLINE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON AB 2364.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. GOOD
MORNING KELLY HITT ON BEHALF OF
ABM IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION?
HI, NATALIE, BOAST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE IN OPPOSITION,
LAWRENCE GAYTAN, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO ONE ELSE COME
FORWARD IN OPPOSITION, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, ANY COMMENTS
OR EMOTION ON. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR GONZALEZ IS OFFERED A
MOTION. WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
AUTHOR FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE'LL
ASK THE ASSISTANT TO RESTATE THE
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL CALL,
PLEASE, FOR FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN, AB 2364. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS, SENATOR CORTEZ,
I CORTEZ I WILK DURAZO.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I LAIRD.
OKAY, WE'RE AT TWO ZERO, BUT
WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS, AND
AGAIN, WE THANK EVERYONE WHO,
APPEARED HERE TO TESTIFY. AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE TESTIMONY ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE, WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM EIGHT NOW.
ALSO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER REBUS AB
2738, AND YOU MAY BEGIN WITH
THAT BILL WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. AB 2738 INCREASES
ENFORCEMENT OF EXISTING LABOR
LAWS IN SEVERAL WAYS. FIRST, IT
MAKES SMALL CHANGES TO A BILL
FROM LAST YEAR THAT GRANTED
LOCAL PUBLIC PROSECUTORS LIKE
CITY ATTORNEYS AND COUNTY
COUNSEL, THE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE STATE LABOR LAW. SECOND,
IT ALLOWS THOSE LOCAL PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS TO ALSO ENFORCE THE
LIVE EVENT WORKER SAFETY LAW
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
BY EXPANDING THEIR AUTHORITY TO
THAT SECTION OF THE LABOR CODE.
LASTLY, IT INCREASES THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LIVE EVENT
WORKER SAFETY LAW BY INCREASING
THE TRANSPARENCY OF CONTRACT
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN ENTERTAINMENT
VENDORS AND PUBLIC VENUES TO
ENSURE THAT STAGE CREWS BEING
HIRED ARE PROPERLY TRAINED, AND
STAGE PRODUCTION WORKERS WHO SET
UP, OPERATE AND TEAR DOWN LIVE
EVENTS FACE SERIOUS WORKPLACE
HAZARDS. THEY WORK WITH COMPLEX
SYSTEMS IN ALL TYPES OF WEATHER
CONDITIONS. THERE IS A HISTORY
OF ACCIDENTS, INJURIES AND EVEN
FATALITIES OF WORKERS PERFORMING
SUCH WORK, OFTEN DUE TO A LACK
OF TRAINING OR KNOWLEDGE OF BEST
SAFETY PRACTICES. THE LACK OF
SAFETY TRAINING AND ENFORCEMENT
IS DANGEROUS FOR WORKERS AND
EVENT ATTENDEES. IN 2022, AB
1775 SET AN INDUSTRY WIDE SAFETY
STANDARD FOR STAGING AND LIVE
EVENTS. PRODUCTION BY REQUIRING
ENTERTAINMENT VENDORS THAT
PRODUCE EVENTS SUCH AS CONCERTS
AT STATE OWNED OR OPERATING
OPERATED FACILITIES TO CERTIFY
THAT ALL ENTERTAINMENT WORKERS
HAVE ADEQUATE AND APPROPRIATE
SAFETY TRAINING. HOWEVER, AB
1775 PUT THE ONUS ON
ENTERTAINMENT VENDORS TO CERTIFY
THAT WORKERS MET THE SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS. THE TEMPORARY
NATURE OF SETTING UP LIVE EVENTS
LIKE CONCERTS, MAKE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CHALLENGING FOR
STATEWIDE ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES,
WITH THOUSANDS OF WORKPLACES TO
INSPECT, AB 2738 STRENGTHENS THE
ENFORCEMENT TO PROTECT STAGE
PRODUCTION WORKERS BY HOLDING
PUBLIC VENUES ACCOUNTABLE AND
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY IN
CONTRACTS TO VERIFY THAT
PRODUCTION COMPANIES ARE USING
TRAINED WORKERS. ADDITIONALLY,
IT EXPANDS THE EXISTING
AUTHORITY OF LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO ENFORCE THE LIVE
EVENT SAFETY LAW AND OTHER LABOR
LAWS TO REDUCE THE BACKLOG AT
STATE AGENCIES. TODAY, I HAVE
OUR SPONSOR, SARAH FOX,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION, AS A WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. GREAT. THANK YOU,
MISS FOX. PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS. SARA FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION, AND THIS IS A
BILL TO ADDRESS THE LABOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
. WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
BACKLOGS, ABOUT CHRONIC
UNDERSTAFFING, BOTH AT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND AT AT
CAL OSHA. AND THIS HAS CAUSED A
LACK OF ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE
BOARD OF CRITICAL SAFETY, OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS AND OF
WAGE AND HOUR LAWS. SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT TAKES THE MODEL
OF AB 594 FROM LAST YEAR, WHICH
GAVE MORE TOOLS TO PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS, TO THOSE CITY
ATTORNEYS, DISTRICT ATTORNEYS,
COUNTY COUNCILS WHO KNOW THAT
THEIR LOCAL ECONOMY, IT GAVE
THEM MORE TOOLS TO ENFORCE LABOR
LAW. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
TAKES THAT GREAT MODEL AND
EXPANDS IT SO THAT THEY CAN NOW
ENFORCE THE SET SAFETY, THE LIVE
EVENT, SET SAFETY LAW. AT THE
SAME TIME, IT ALSO ENSURES THAT
THESE OFFICES THAT ARE SPRINGING
UP IN CITIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE
STATE FUNDING. SO IN FIVE NINE,
FOUR IT WAS NOT MANDATORY THAT
THESE PUBLIC PROSECUTOR'S
OFFICES WERE AWARDED ATTORNEY'S
FEES AND COSTS WHEN THEY WERE
THE PREVAILING PARTIES. THIS
BILL CHANGES THAT. IT SAYS THAT
THEY SHALL GET ATTORNEY'S FEES
AND COSTS WHEN THEY ARE THE
PREVAILING PARTY, SO THAT THEY
HAVE AN INCENTIVE AND A FUNDING
SOURCE TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
BRINGING THESE CASES. AND THIS
IS I'M JUST GOING TO EMPHASIZE
THIS AGAIN, THIS IS FOR PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS LIKE YOUR CITY
ATTORNEY, YOUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. THIS IS NOT FOR
PRIVATE LAW FIRMS. AND IT IS A
SIMPLE WAY THAT WE'RE NOT WE
DON'T NEED TO USE STATE FUNDING.
AND YET WE CAN INCREASE LABOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT. ALSO TAKING THE
BURDEN OFF OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND NOW CAL OSHA,
THANKS TO THIS BILL. SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT
WITNESS, MR. CHAIR MEMBERS MATT
BROD HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS. CA UNITE HERE, ATU
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS THE SUPPORT,
POSITION, NAME AND AFFILIATION.
SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS? WELCOME. DO
YOU HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES, GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATOR.
MY NAME IS SABRINA LOCKHART. I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTRACTIONS AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA THEME PARKS, WATER
PARKS, FAMILY ENTERTAINMENT
CENTERS, AS WELL AS THE
BUSINESSES THAT PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AND
EQUIPMENT TO OUR INDUSTRY. OUR
MEMBERS ARE EMPLOYERS OF ALL
SIZES. WE HAVE MULTIPLE
GENERATIONAL, FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS AS
MEMBERS. WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO
JUST THE PROVISION IN THIS BILL
THAT REQUIRES COURTS TO AWARD
ATTORNEYS FEES IN CASES, RATHER
THAN GIVING THEM THE DISCRETION.
LAST YEAR, WE VOICED CONCERNS
THAT PUBLIC ENTITIES WILL LIKELY
CONTRACT OUT WITH PRIVATE LAW
FIRMS FOR THIS LITIGATION, AND
LAST YEAR'S MEASURE, AB 5.94,
ONLY TOOK EFFECT IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR. THE AUTHOR TOOK
AMENDMENTS LAST YEAR TO REMOVE
MANDATORY COURT AWARDS AND THIS
BILL REVERSES THOSE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN LAST YEAR. AB 2738 INSTEAD
FORCES COURTS TO AWARD FEES,
CREATING A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
FOR PRIVATE ATTORNEYS TO FILE
CLAIMS AGAINST BUSINESSES
REGARDLESS OF MERIT. THE CURRENT
SYSTEM, WHERE COURTS DECIDE WHO
GETS REIMBURSED, ENSURES THAT
JUSTICE IS SERVED FOR LEGITIMATE
GRIEVANCES NOT EXPLOITED FOR
FINANCIAL GAIN. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE OPPOSE AB 2738.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, ARE YOU A SECOND LEAD
WITNESS COMING UP? ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THEN NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, BRIAN LITTLE,
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. OKAY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, STEPHANIE
ROBERSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION, THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
ANALLY AUGUSTINE, ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE, ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS? WE HAVE
AN OFFER BY SENATOR GONZALEZ TO
MOVE THE RECOMMENDATION ON THE
BILL, LET ME JUST SAY, TO WITH
REFERENCE TO ALL THE TESTIMONY
OF THE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN. HAVING
PRACTICED LAW AND ALSO HAVING
SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHERE
SOME OF THIS ENFORCEMENT WILL
TAKE PLACE, I UNDERSTAND WHY
FOLKS WOULD SPEAK UP ABOUT THAT,
BUT I THINK THE ISSUE IS THAT,
LARGER CITIES AND COUNTIES WILL
BE DOING THIS IN-HOUSE. THEY
HAVE A LOT OF REASONS TO DO
THAT. AND A NUMBER OF LEVELS,
AND I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
UNLEVEL PLAYING FIELD OF PERHAPS
A LARGE, DEFENDANT AGAINST A
MUCH SMALLER ENTITY SOMEWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA, NOT ONE OF OUR LARGE
CITIES OF 250,000 OR MORE, FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY WOULD BE AT A
SEVERE DISADVANTAGE IF THEY
COULDN'T BRING IN COUNSEL. AND,
AT LEAST HAVE TO TAKE THE GAMBLE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO SUCCEED.
AND BE ABLE TO RECOUP ATTORNEY'S
FEES. SO I THINK IT'S FAIR,
OBVIOUSLY ALL THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION IS, A MATTER OF ROAD
TESTING. AT SOME POINT, WE FIND
OUT HOW IT WORKS, HOW IT DOESN'T
WORK, BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT THAT THE SUPPORT
WITNESS EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS,
IT'S NOT A SITUATION. OUR
PLAINTIFF, PRIVATE PLAINTIFF
COUNSEL SITUATION HERE IT IS
TRYING TO EMPOWER, PUBLIC SECTOR
PROSECUTORS IF, AS I'M
UNDERSTANDING THE BILL AND
THEREFORE, I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL, SO I'LL COME BACK, TO
THE AUTHOR FOR ANY OPPORTUNITY
YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND FOR
SUPPORTING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I'LL
ASK THE ASSISTANT TO RESTATE THE
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL,
PLEASE. ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB 2738. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR CORTEZ Ã
CORTEZ. AYE. WILK GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE LAIRD. RIGHT.
WE'RE AT 2 TO 0. WE'LL KEEP THE
BILL ON CALL, AND WE EXPECT TO
HAVE SOME MEMBERS, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BACK HERE SOON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
EVERYONE, FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
GREAT. WE DO HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CERVANTES HERE
ON FILE ITEM SIX AB 2167, WHICH
I BELIEVE WILL BE OUR LAST
PRESENTATION TODAY. AND MAYBE WE
CAN GET SOME HELP TO START
TRYING TO GET MEMBERS BACK HERE
FOR A FEW MINUTES TO LIFT THE
CALL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
YOU CAN PROCEED. THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND SENATORS, FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2167, A BILL THAT WOULD MAKE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO AND ELIGIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
STATING THAT I AM ASKING THIS
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE AUTHOR'S
AMENDMENTS, DESCRIBED ON PAGE
THREE OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS,
AND I DO WANT TO THANK THE STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR ASSISTANCE ON THIS
BILL, AS AMENDED. AB 2167 WILL
MAKE APPLYING FOR BOTH PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE BENEFITS
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS. BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE WAGE
REPLACEMENTS DURING LEAVE FROM
WORK AFTER THE BIRTH OR ADOPTION
OF A CHILD. BIRTHING PEOPLE
COMMONLY USE A COMBINATION OF
BOTH P, FL, AND SDI PROGRAMS FOR
THIS PURPOSE. STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE IS AVAILABLE FOR
BIRTHING PEOPLE UP TO SIX WEEKS
AFTER A VAGINAL BIRTH, AND UP TO
EIGHT WEEKS AFTER BIRTH BY
CAESAREAN BIRTHING. PEOPLE CAN
THEN ACCESS UP TO EIGHT WEEKS OF
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM. ONCE
THEY HAVE EXHAUSTED THEIR SDI
ELIGIBILITY. MEANWHILE, ELIGIBLE
NON-BIRTHING PARTNERS CAN ACCESS
UP TO EIGHT WEEKS OF FL BENEFITS
AFTER BIRTH OR ADOPTION FOR
BONDING TIME WITH THE NEW CHILD.
HOWEVER, APPLYING FOR FL AND SDI
BENEFITS CAN BE COMPLICATED IN
TIME CONSUMING. THE FINAL MONTHS
OF PREGNANCY ARE WELCOMING A
NEWBORN OR A NEWLY ADOPTED CHILD
OR TRANSFORMATIONAL EVENTS. MANY
PAID FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS CGRTS
MORE. WE NEED TO MAKE THEM MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO HELP WITH LOWERING
STRESS AMONG BIRTHING PEOPLE AND
THEIR PARTNERS DURING PREGNANCY,
ESPECIALLY ANY WORRIES OVER
FINANCIAL SECURITY. THE EXISTING
FL AND STATE DISABILITY PROGRAMS
ONLY PROVIDE A 41 DAY WINDOW TO
APPLY FOR BENEFITS, AND THIS
WINDOW TO APPLY ONLY OPENS ON
THE WORKER'S FIRST DAY OF LEAVE.
WORKERS CANNOT APPLY BEFORE
THEIR LEAVE BEGINS. THE
RESTRICTIVE AND LIMITED NATURE
OF THIS APPLICATION WINDOW IS
NOT REFLECTIVE OF REAL LIFE. MY
BILL SEEKS TO FOSTER A MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND SUPPORTIVE
APPLICATION PROCESS BY ALLOWING
ELIGIBLE WORKERS TO HAVE MORE
TIME TO APPLY FOR PAID FAMILY
LEAVE BENEFITS. THIS BILL WOULD
ACCOMPLISH THIS BY PERMITTING
EARLY APPLICATION FOR FL AND SDI
UP TO 60 DAYS BEFORE A WORKER'S
FIRST DAY OF LEAVE. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO ADJUST THE TIMELINE
FOR AN APPEAL OF A DENIAL OF FL
AND SDI BENEFITS, EXTENDING THE
WINDOW FOR WORKERS TO APPEAL
FROM 30 DAYS TO 60 DAYS. THIS
WILL GIVE FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO APPLY FOR THESE BENEFITS
WHILE NAVIGATING THE LIFE
CHANGES ASSOCIATED WITH
WELCOMING A NEW FAMILY MEMBER.
WE KNOW THAT MANY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAD DONE AN IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF WORK IN RECENT YEARS
TO AUGMENT FL AND SDI BENEFITS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL IS
A FOLLOW UP TO THOSE EFFORTS,
AND A RESPONSE TO THE ISSUES
THAT MANY CALIFORNIANS HAVE
FACED IN ACCESSING THESE
BENEFITS BY MAKING THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND NØ
NØ, LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES ON
THIS ONE. THAT'S FINE. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO WALK UP AND EXPRESS A
SUPPORT POSITION? THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. RYAN SPENCER, ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OB
GYN'S DISTRICT NINE, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. ANYONE ELSE
ON THE SUPPORT SIDE, SEEING NO
ONE COME FORWARD, IS THERE AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS? I SEE NO
WITNESSES COME FORWARD ON IN
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS AN OPPOSITION
POSITION IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM?
SEEING NO ONE COME FORWARD,
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, WE CAN TAKE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS OR ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. SENATOR DURAZZO, I MOVE
THE BILL AND I ALSO ASK THE
AUTHOR. WE HAVE VERY SIMILAR
BILLS MOVING FORWARD RIGHT NOW,
SO I DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO HELP
YOU. MAYBE COAUTHOR, BUT
ABSOLUTELY. FOR TODAY, MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU, SENATOR DURAZZO
, WITH THAT, YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF YOU LIKE.
YES. I DO RECOGNIZE WE DO HAVE
SIMILARITIES, BETWEEN OUR TWO
BILLS AND CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD
TO COLLABORATING TOGETHER ON
THESE EFFORTS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL ASK THE ASSISTANT TO
RESTATE THE MOTION, WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. YES, SENATOR RUSSELL.
THAT'S RIGHT, TO RESTATE THE
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL,
PLEASE. YES. ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX, AB 2167, THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. AS
SENATOR CORTEZ. AYE. CORTEZ. I
WILK I WILK I DURAZZO. I
DURAZZO. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
I LAIRD I LAIRD I THAT BILL IS
OUT WITH FIVE ZERO. ALL RIGHT.
FIVE ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU, WE ARE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL. AT THIS POINT, I'LL
ASK THE ASSISTANT TO PROCEED.
STARTING AT THE TOP OF THE FILE,
ORDER, FILE ITEM ONE, THE MOTION
IS DO PASS, AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CHAIR IS VOTING AYE, SENATOR
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE FIVE ZERO.
THE BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 2182 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAYNIE. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
THE JUDICIARY, THE CHAIR IS
VOTING AYE. SENATOR WILK NOT
VOTING. WILK NOT VOTING. SO 4 TO
0, WITH ONE NOT VOTING, THE BILL
IS OUT. THANK YOU. ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE, THE AB 1997 WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR WILK, I WILK I SENATOR
LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. ALL RIGHT.
FIVE ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU. ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE, THE MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. THIS IS AB 2135. THE
CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK NOT VOTING. WILK NOT
VOTING. SENATOR LAIRD. Ã.
LAIRD. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT'S
FOUR ZERO WITH ONE NOT VOTING.
THE BILL IS OUT. WE'LL MOVE NOW
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, AB
2364 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF
US. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AND THE CHAIR IS VOTING AYE.
SENATOR WILK NÓ WILK NÓ DURAZZO.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD
AYE. THAT'S FOUR ONE. THE BILL
IS UP ON FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
BY AB 2738 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR WILK NØ.
WILK. NØ. SENATOR DURAZZO. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE. SENATOR. LAIRD.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. FOUR ONE. THAT
IS 4 TO 1. THE BILL IS OUT. ON
FILE. ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2705
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY. THE
CHAIR IS VOTING AYE. SENATOR
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE. SENATOR
LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD. AYE THE BILL
IS OUT. ON FILE ITEM NUMBER 13,
AB 2971 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CHAIR IS
VOTING AYE. SENATOR WILK NØ.
WILK NØ. SENATOR DURAZZO, I.
DURAZZO. AYE. SENATOR. LAIRD Ã.
LAIRD AYE. 4 TO 1. THE BILL IS
OUT. AND FINALLY ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER 14, AB 3025 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALENCIA. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
THE JUDICIARY. SENATOR WILK AYE.
WILK AYE. SENATOR DURAZZO I
DURAZZO. AYE SENATOR. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. FIVE ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT. PICKED UP ON CONSENT
ALREADY, RIGHT? YES. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT. ALL RIGHT.
WELL, THAT CONCLUDES OKAY. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR OUR HEARING TODAY
AND WE'VE COMPLETED OUR AGENDA.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR MOVING
AROUND EFFICIENTLY AND HELPING
US TO KEEP THE AGENDA MOVING
TODAY. AND I WANT TO ESPECIALLY
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF. I
OBVIOUSLY WAS SUBSTITUTE CHAIR
TODAY, BECAUSE SENATOR SMALL
CUEVAS WAS OUT, BUT I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF TODAY. IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WAS UNABLE TO
TESTIFY FOR ANY REASON TODAY, I
THOUGHT WE ALLOWED AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY. BUT YOU'RE WELCOME
TO SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
THAT CAN BE DONE THROUGH THE
ONLINE SYSTEM. AGAIN, THANK YOU
EVERYONE, AND THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. WE ARE
ADJOURNED. AND THANKS TO YOU.